did you get like an overwhelming amount
of people in your twitch chat asking if
we were going to god's wedding or when
god's wedding was as if they're like
they're also planning to go but they
were like they're like you're gonna film
it right i'm like no
no sometimes people are like so this is
this is like a trash tape
[ __ ] rocks are one of those [ __ ]
film cameras like yo what's going on
gopro on every corner of the room
come on it's got like a gopro
[ __ ] forehead like pov
welcome to this episode of trash taste
uh i'm connor and i'm with the boys joey
and gone hey
guys how many weeks has it been many it
has been many a month i think you do not
know this but uh
i've flown back to england and flown
back to japan in the time yeah uh since
the last not even the last record and
then you gotta go like a week later
again so why'd you leave a scan why did
i leave um basically i had to do a
marriage interview now normally people
do it like a year or something before
their wedding but unfortunately due to
uh yeah due to like travel restrictions
i didn't have the opportunity
to uh go back to england to basically do
this marriage interview which is like
legally wait did you fill me in what do
you have to do at a marriage okay
yeah you haven't got a job yeah yeah
yeah okay okay i'll get so why do you
want to get married
i'll get into why like we like i had to
do it but yeah legally like if i wanted
to be married in the uk
you need to give something called a
notice of marriage which is basically
you're telling the government that
you're like planning to get married um
and so it
brings you to the legal proceedings to
allow you to get married now right
so normally you can do that like a year
or months before unfortunately due to
travel restrictions and like us not
being able to travel back to the uk or
just being incredibly difficult uh we
kind of like put that off and we put
that off and we put that off and we put
that off and then
you you have to legally give it at least
28 days before you get married and by
the time we gave it it was like
35 days before we got married so
are you still still on the guidelines
yeah it's it's still in the guidelines
but it was kind of awkward because i had
to leave the boys for just like two
weeks or something like just kid who
finishes the assignment the day before
i got plenty of time i've got a couple
of hours left yeah so i was like looking
at the schedule and i'm just like
[ __ ] we got like trash taste and all
this other work stuff that we need to be
doing and i gotta give my notice of
marriage otherwise i can't legally
legally get married and yeah i put this
ass i've put this off for as long as
possible but it's just it just makes it
a bit awkward because otherwise i would
have traveled back to the uk a little
bit later yeah um because now i'm back
just for literally like about eight days
just to
do like my filming commitments and film
all the trash chase episodes we need to
film yeah um so yeah i don't even know
if i'm going to like tweet out that i'm
back in japan because like it's honestly
not worth it because by the time i
tweeted out i'm going to be tweeting out
okay i'm back in the uk now um and so
another thing is that this is probably
like the most timely trash taste episode
you'll ever be able to see uh because we
are filming this like what like three
days three days three days before uh it
actually airs or something like that
yeah so um it's like the one time there
where we can talk about current topics
and it's the one time where it's just
like there isn't really any current
topics yeah
before we started we were like all right
guys it's finally time we can talk about
some timely things and we just sat here
for five minutes trying to think of a
timely subject yeah we couldn't think of
anything
we should just pick something like
really irrelevant yeah
that's crazy
oh my god yeah but yeah basically this
notices marriages it was mostly just
like
you know about lawful procedures
um just making sure that uh we can we
can be lawfully married uh so like
normally they just ask you like normal
questions like oh i was being asked you
know what is spell spell your fiancee's
name you know what's what is her name
hopefully i know her name
really that's like that's like gotcha
yeah yeah yeah yeah no he's like spell
her name and then uh ask uh you know
what is her birthday you know uh i don't
actually know what would have happened
if i failed by the way yeah like like
what if i didn't know about it
my last name is a pretty tricky one to
spell but it makes no sense so if i got
it wrong i wouldn't be like oh
i think they want to check that it's not
like a sham marriage of course yeah like
like you're not just doing it for the
visa yeah yeah yeah exactly but uh yeah
hopefully you can spell your partner's
name know their birthday if you don't
now that you know what's going to be
asked you need to know where you're
getting married this will be on the tip
and it is a test because like they
separate you right they're like okay
this is we're just going to be asking
some simple questions whatever and like
even though i know like it was simple
questions just like being separated it
was kind of like
it kind of felt like being in like an
interrogation like why are you here why
are you getting married
like is she your real is she your real
wife she could be your real wife no but
it was not it was nothing bad like they
were just like you know just details
about basic details you hopefully should
know about your future wife and
everything like that um and then we get
to the end of the interview and then
they [ __ ] throw you a curveball right
so here's me asking why are you going
here's here's me here's me asking uh
being asked to spell sydney's name what
is sydney's name what's sydney's
birthday where are we getting married
when are we getting married yeah one of
my parents names et cetera et cetera and
then out of nowhere they are they just
ask you
are you in any way related to sydney and
ponywars and i'm just like what do you
mean related as in like brother sister
cousin anything like that and i i
i mean hopefully i'm about to me
i just like [ __ ] the [ __ ] orimon
music starts playing my mind i'm like yo
is this guy is this person a gigantic
like it was like
it was it was so out of left field that
i literally just like
and then like i i like let out a laugh
i'm like
and i looked them in the eye and they
just like look me like dead ass back
just like no this is this is a serious
question this is a serious question i'm
like
no i am not related i'm not brother or
sister i'm not her cousin or anything
like that and uh
just
what if they were just like does this
song ring any bells and just plays clara
it's like
does this give you any weird feelings
yeah i'm like they actually said
afterwards like you'd be surprised how
many people say yes really like well i
didn't realize i was getting married in
the state of alabama here like
yeah apparently it's like it's it's
surprising how many like first cousins
try to get married like like i guess
there's a lot of groups that
have a tendency to marry within family
yeah like do you fail the test if you
say yes to that or do they just like
they're like okay i i don't know
it's the incest test okay
what happens if you fail the incest test
i don't know
mary if it's a certain
closeness right yeah yeah yeah you can't
in the eye first cousins i believe in
the uk you definitely can't marry if
your brother's sister i'm not sure
about first cousins
i don't know
how many degrees of separation i ever
need to worry about
like how many degrees of separation does
it have to be yeah i don't know
i'm asking for a friend he's like google
when you google this just when you
google this too much google's like for
real yeah
are you nasty man
it's perfectly legal for first countries
to marry in the uk is it is it actually
okay okay so if you say yes to that
question then they'll be like we'll
allow it we're just gonna silently
because because they didn't they didn't
just ask you know legally by blood they
were like we include step siblings as
well i'm just like
domestic girlfriend all over again
please don't get money please don't get
honey
i'm like i've been training my entire
life for this moment how did they know
what my favorite tags were
i'm just nervous i swear i'm just
nervous
what are the only ones like you're 23
and me to like
what are they
because we did we were like legally like
we had to legally prepare like most of
the documents
no so we had to prepare documents which
is all like the standard documents you
would think you would need to prepare
for like a marriage interview like you
know just you know um your passports
your uh
since we're flying in you know your
tickets are flying in your proof of
address or or like the standard legal
documents so everything else could be
easily proved via our documents i don't
know where how you prove like whether
you're like incest or not like what if
you say yes like well what what what
documents would you need to provide
high five
nice yeah
i'm just asking
that
like is there like a [ __ ] incest
tinder or something
yeah i believe that's facebook
it's just facebook right
[Laughter]
have you joined any of these facebook
groups
oh my god
was it hard to get the manager to get
live yeah kind of just documents i mean
i guess you've you've lived in japan so
maybe getting documents and stuff is
like easy mode yeah it's like it's it's
actually uh i mean
it's
harder to get the documents and now that
we live outside of japan because
originally we wanted a church wedding
and the more we looked into it the
[ __ ] the the harder it was mostly
because uh one you know i'm not
christian it's only sydney
um and also a lot of churches in the uk
are very strict about who they allow to
get married there or like the priest so
a lot of the times you need to be like a
regular at the church and if you're not
already have attended like when you're a
kid or a regular or your family goes
there then you need to attend for like
you know like a month or something just
so just so the priest knows you and now
that just wasn't an option for us
because you know it's it's hard enough
taking a two-week holiday away from the
boys you know i mean i couldn't just go
back to be like guys i got an attention
unfortunately we couldn't get a church
wedding but you know that's all fine we
can still
it's everything is all ready now legally
we are you know we've booked the place
we've booked the registrar decided to go
i am so excited to go i'm so excited for
you boys to go as well all you can eat
right huh or you can eat right i heard
yeah yeah yeah right yeah
i won't i won't spoil everything that we
have planned
before the wedding my only question is
there food
that's all i need to know there is there
is food yeah yeah aside from like
planning my own wedding i actually also
was able to attend a friend's wedding
while i was back as well it was a very
very packed
very very packed trip for me i literally
uh attended this wedding and then the
day after i flew back to japan to uh
meet um
meet uh the other boys i guess and the
other boys
my other spouses as the city says
my boyfriend yeah yeah and like it was
so surreal because it was the first
mates wedding i've been to and
it was so surreal because a lot of
weddings now um have been delayed to
this year because obviously we've
covered and everything that's that
includes me so this one this year is
just [ __ ] packed for weddings like i
think you're you're on a three you're
getting three wins this year aren't you
i'm going to yours i'm going to my
friends in ireland and then i'm going to
my cousins in japan yeah yeah and all of
them have were supposed to happen like
two years ago yeah yeah exactly all this
year yeah so a lot of weddings have been
postponed to this year so i basically
just got like
like i basically got to see
what a wedding is going to be like and
like you know seeing my mate get married
and everything and seeing everything
from the audience perspective before uh
before i up there standing up there
myself you did the beta test i did the
beta test right
this is pretty good i think we can go
forward soon yeah and i'll i'll be
honest man i was [ __ ] nervous as [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] like it was
someone else's wedding yeah someone else
right right because because it's like uh
i've i've known this guy for like almost
as long as i've known sydney right so um
i remember just
being in the audience and seeing him
stand up there and waiting for the bride
to come out um just seeing him try to
keep it together just like made me like
think [ __ ] man like i'm feeling your
nerves right now because i know
everything he's like going through and
i'm just like this is going to be me in
a month i i
i thought to myself [ __ ] if i'm this
nervous
in the crowd how am i going to be
when i'm up there like when when i'm up
there guys
there's gonna be an element of stage
fright right because you have to like do
something in front of all your friends
yeah yeah yeah yeah
it was it was actually so funny though
because uh it was like we were waiting
in the venue where
uh where all the family was and the
groom was up there on stage with um uh
with the wedding party and everything
and you know we had like this beautiful
heart playing and everyone was like
silence and then there was just like
this this small pause right as the
harpist was like changing to the next
song uh the bride was already like
was was already like uh i believe five
to ten minutes after you know the
ceremony had already been scheduled to
happen so you know we
we weren't nervous but it was just like
tense you know you could like
you could cut the tension with a knife
and everyone was everyone wasn't talking
and then there was this brief silence um
and then out of nowhere
um because sydney was like one of the
bridesmaids right out of out of nowhere
we just hear
in the corner like just someone going
yes girl
oh god
and and that just like and and that just
everyone just like started laughing like
the tension was gone for just like
tension was just like instantly gone
give whoever said that a metal plate
but no it was uh it was yeah it was it
was
it's it's weird attending a mate's
wedding i'm i'm curious
i'm curious to see how you guys react
well because for me like i was just
after it was over it's just such a nice
feeling it was like the most like
like every cliche you could imagine but
it's like cliche in a nice way because
it's it's it's how everyone describes
being at a wedding but like you're just
drunk on positive vibes you know you're
just like you was you're just so happy
for
uh for the couple in the future and the
bride in the groom and just seeing them
tie the knot and just
seeing them go through all that after
you know both of them and after you've
seen them like you know build up their
relationship it's just such a weird
moment to see just just to see
everything culminate into this one
awesome moment and it's just awesome
it's so wholesome oh god i was just i'm
still like i'm still like glowing from
like positive vibes from that event i'm
just like damn man i can't i can't wait
i can't wait i can't wait
i'm hyped i'm very quiet
interesting because it's like my friends
in japan and my friends in the uk are
going to see each other yeah so the same
thing for you it's gonna be strange yeah
yeah yeah cause we i was telling the
corner earlier where you know mostly
it's like for a lot of people it's just
going to be our japan lot and our
uk friends meeting for the first time
and connor's the only one who is kind of
like got you know
bridging between everyone you know he
knows everyone basically it's gonna be
interesting yeah because you know
normally you when your friends groups
live in other countries they don't
normally interact with each other yeah
it's gonna be really interesting yeah
actually one of the funnest parts of the
wedding planning because we've been
doing like a lot of wedding planning
some of it you know some of it's
stressful some of it not but like by far
the most funnest point uh is i get to
choose who sits next to each other in
puzzle level difficulties
so we're so a lot of like some wedding
some winning parties you know they they
do like a like a soft segregation
between you know that
and it it it is what it feels like
discrimination is always necessary you
know
discrimination it's soft segregation
that's what we're doing that's what
we're calling it right because
sometimes you go to a wedding you're
like you can clearly see you know that's
the family table that's you know the one
friend group table that's the other
friend group table yeah because you
always have people you have to invite
right you're like yeah i have to invite
them but i know they're gonna they
they're gonna cause problems yeah yeah i
put them near other people
so we decided to do to do something a
little different uh without spoiling
who's six
sits next to who we had a fun time being
like who who would get along with who
uh while not knowing each other too well
so we we had to think about you know
what kind of personalities would get on
so we didn't sit we didn't sit people
next to each other who they might
might be so familiar with you know not
too far away from just being completely
strangers but uh it was it was a fun
time just you know just kind of like
kind of like pairing people up and
pairing like friendship groups up and
just seeing like the absolute state of
some of the tables that we have planned
because we've basically just put all of
like the [ __ ] big characters on one
table oh no
um
and yeah it's it's uh it's gonna be a
lot of fun just to see
just to see if you guys get along well
with each other because it's it's like
as you said it's like two friendship
groups kind of merging because i don't
actually have so much family like so
much family coming to my wedding it's
actually like a small wedding in
comparison to other weddings i've been
to like i don't know what do you guys
count as a small
wedding
most of the weddings i've been to have
been very much dominated by family
yeah ours is like 80
mates that's good yeah that's good yeah
so like yeah because like i know like
every small small weddings or
medium-sized wedding is like different
depending on like whatever culture
you're from like you know 100 100 people
is like i'd say like a medium-sized
wedding you know that's that's medium
you know 100 people was like tiny
compared to an indian wedding you know
yeah i was talking to like i was talking
to a guy who like went to an indian
wedding and then they had like a
thousand people going or something
that's that's a concert
like indian weddings are basically what
happened if you actually go on your
facebook group and you invite everyone
in your friends
yeah and everyone said yes
yeah yeah right
like i know like part of the reason uh
so we're actually
you know part of the reason because we
do have a massive family but we didn't
want a massive like a massive massive
wedding because that's just like such a
headache so we're just like you know
what we're gonna have the main wedding
in the uk and then we'll be we'll bring
the wedding to the family we'll we'll
we'll go on tour you know what i mean
we'll go on tour the waiting tour
so yeah we're having like we're having
like a different kind of
reception kind of thing for like our
family in the us and thailand like you
know way after that'd be nice though
yeah way off the wedding dude sorry i'm
hitting up all the spots this is the
world wide
wedding one tour of the world you
already had one wedding cricket
yeah because like i don't know like i i
would i want to be able to talk to
be able to talk to everyone at my
wedding and you know share the positive
vibe
when you get over to like 100 or 150
people which yeah it definitely would
have been our wedding if we invited all
of the family from like our beaufort
side from abroad
um you just like you get to a point
where
it's our wedding it's meant to be like
our happiest moment but you don't get
time to share it with the people that
you want to share right you know you see
everyone talking but you you like most
of your interactions you're just like oh
you're having a good time you have like
a five minute conversation and that's it
you know it's basically just like going
to a convention you know and go into
like a panel or something because that's
that's the amount of interaction i have
with people who you know line up for a
meet-up or something yeah i i want more
of an interaction and more time to like
get to get to vibe with people at my own
[ __ ] wedding i guess so yeah yeah i
don't know i don't know how people
handle like massive [ __ ] weddings of
like you know 300 500 whatever you know
yeah because i've been to i went to my
like um
my friend's wedding like japanese guy
who i went to university with and like
it's a tradition i don't know if it's
like a full-on tradition but like
usually the tradition is like if you
have like a full-time job like you
already have enjoyed your college yeah
your colleagues and you invite your
bosses oh yeah the boss has to come in
yeah yeah as well so like i went to it
and uh you know the the soft segregation
happening and like i was on the table of
like mates who i went to school with you
know yeah but we realized that was one
table out of like 40 tables that were
there
because there was like there was
probably like 400 people at this wedding
yeah all work colleagues like all bosses
and like all family and there was just
like me and like three schoolmates who
they've been like yeah so have you been
it's been a while i don't know any of
these other people but uh good wedding
yeah
did you have to like line up to give
your blessing because i've i've been to
some weddings where we have to do that
yeah yeah yeah like you have to give
your blessing what's that yeah because
because there is so many people at the
wedding right and the the bride and
groom only have so much time everyone
takes turn lining up yeah
like i went to a thai wedding where i we
literally had to line up to be like
congratulations guys and there was there
was they had like the stage where like
they sat on like a [ __ ] sofa or
whatever they weren't even into like
white people weddings so i don't i
literally had to line up to like shake
my mate yeah
just yeah because it was like because
like you know after the reception and
everything and you know during like you
know the food and stuff like that and
they're kind of like walking around and
stuff you know saying hello to everyone
yeah like uh yeah good system though
yeah i mean it's a good system but it
was also weird just like lining up next
to like a bunch of salarymen to be like
oh i'm just here to shake my hand you
know efficiently i like it i like the
efficiency of it yeah
oh you didn't see me wedding shut up we
got five minutes in a handshake
it's like an idol like yeah yeah
how many of my albums did you buy
i bought 10 of your cds you know you're
just in the in the like wedding
asian weddings as well when you're
lining up sometimes you haven't even
slipped some money to like pass
i don't know if this feels quite insane
but it just feels like the supreme store
of weddings like asian asian weddings
are it's like how much can you flex just
everyone brings it like supreme out
everyone's like oh yeah of course
spread dude way more food than you'd
ever need yeah yeah yeah bring everyone
you know why just so i can have the
capacity bigger on facebook yeah because
it's like a lot of asian weddings i've
been to it's it's it's like a statement
you know what i mean it's it's it's like
it's about sending a message
it is literally about sending a message
trying to tell people how successful you
are it's like what's the
i think it's also about like look at how
like happy we are and look at then like
this is like the physical representation
of how like yeah you know happy and like
well-off we are for being happy yeah
because like the amount of
wedding politics that go into an asian
it is a thing it is a thing right
because it's it's not even it's not even
about inviting your immediate friends
and family you got like your parents
immediate like friends and family and
people you grew up with and everything
like that there's like
if you are not invited to an asian
wedding
you're [ __ ] up in some way you know
what i mean this legend sounds like the
red wedding from game of thrones it is
you failed to invite me to the wedding
thus you have to portray my clan
you will die now you have insulted the
house of manitoba
you will not be forgiven for this
i didn't want i didn't want like that
side just like involved in my wedding
yeah
there is another
[Laughter]
the scroll comes
fear not we are bringing the wedding to
you
[Laughter]
first open the doors
yeah i mean like it's like i've like
every asian wedding i've been to is like
the most extra thing i've ever seen in
the world um and like it's unfortunate
that is also it's also extrapolated by
the fact that every asian family i know
is [ __ ] massive it's absolutely
massive you you have to conversely
southeast asia especially oh my god if
like if i had if i had my wedding and so
i don't have to invite all my cousins
and all like my customers
um so yeah like that's that's like i
definitely would not have been able to
plan that
um along with just being outside the
country so i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm
just gonna have a small manageable
wedding
um and just enjoy it right and just and
just enjoy the wedding yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude yeah that sounds nice i'm excited
for it man did you get like an
overwhelming amount of people in your
twitch chat asking if we were going to
dance wedding or when god's wedding was
as if they're like they're also planning
to go but they were like they were like
you're going to film it right i'm like
no
no
i got that so many times people are like
so this is this is like a trash taste
special
it's like the wedding special he's like
no
could you imagine if i just like rocked
up with a [ __ ] camera being like all
right so uh [ __ ] rock someone like
the [ __ ] film camera yo what's going
on we've got like [ __ ] ten different
video crews just like filming every
angle of this wedding gopro on every
corner of the room
come on it's got like a gopro
yeah i mean like
it was actually like i barely took any
pictures at the wedding i attended like
because one you know one i just felt
like you know we have we have some
pictures but it was more pictures to
share in between our mates and you know
we might we'll probably share yeah me
and cindy will probably show the wedding
yeah
yeah i don't know how much we're gonna
share to social media yeah i don't know
yet you know it's kind of it's kind of
i'll decide can't be wearing a suit and
sydney wearing a dress
that's pretty yeah
and everyone will be nice
it's not gonna be any different just
because really youtubers who are not
like yeah they're like whoa
like it's just i don't know
it's just like a gold play button in the
middle right that'd be here yeah
susan comes down dude
really happy trash taste
for you susan comes and gives her a
blessing
we say our vows
one get out of demonetization freaky
yeah i don't know like there have been
like other youtubers who have you know
very much documented their wedding and
you know everyone's different in terms
of choosing how much they wish to share
you know it's entirely up to everyone
but you have to understand that
everyone's a bit different in terms of
how much they choose to share
um because it is a very private event
yeah you gotta respect the privacy it's
it's a wedding so the way i see about it
is that you know i'm only gonna get like
one wedding in my life so how much of
this do i want to share with the world
how much of this do i want to keep
between myself and my close mates and
family i don't know yet i don't know yet
i'll i'll think about it and we'll
decide content
yeah because like what are your one
wedding cards
like it's cause like you always like you
you always
you always have to battle the thought of
like you know that whatever you post
it's going to get like the most
engagement
of course that you're ever going to get
if i post a video of this i know it's
going to get [ __ ] like 2 three
million views man easy easy and that's
that's free content you know i don't
even have to i'm gonna do it anyway
that's just free content
it's like honey i know this is like a
really like personal thing but that
click right through like
might be a good place to actually put it
out bro imagine if we're like [ __ ]
live streamed imagine the [ __ ] super
chats man
like youtubers could like v v
could dream of getting the super chat
man please god will not say his vows
until we get at least two grand
we are not moving from this spot
yeah are you excited to go you guys
excited to go to england though because
uh yeah
it's going to be your second time in
england right second first time
first one doesn't count what do you mean
i was barely you barely saw anything
yeah you were there for like how long
like i don't even remember like five
days i think not even a week i don't
think thank you good weather spoons this
time yeah you took me to
arguably one of the shittiest was
probably the [ __ ] is weather spoons yeah
yeah
you still haven't taken me to the
[ __ ] uh like you haven't still you
still haven't given me like a tesco meal
deal or anything oh we'll do that too i
thought maybe should i do like a
tearless video i don't know i shouldn't
say that on camera because then people
will now expect it almost like a meal
deal tier list
like the optimum thing because someone
like i i we spoke about it wait wait did
we speak about it on on the episode no
no we did not sean but i [ __ ] won't
speak about it uh
[ __ ] what am i going to say now though
new deal tier list
i'll do a meal deal how many meal deals
are there
combinations endless jay really
endless damn
there's there's quite a lot actually
depending on which stores you go to
different things so yeah it's really
yeah
is that is that what the weight is
like my wedding my weight i'm like yo
the meal deal combination
let me just let me show you about that
it's gonna be a dance winning right
you can use any tesco meal deal you want
baby
everyone else is going to get like a
nice fancy like five
meals
and i'm connoisseur we're just going to
give him a meal
is worth five pounds retail
i got a three pound fifty mike fell down
bro
he's like yo you're gonna build what
no i'm excited though cause like you
know greg's as well you gotta get greg
what's going on
pasties oh the pasties places yeah yeah
yeah i gotta i gotta try this i gotta
try these pastries well i mean like you
know because we're probably gonna be
there for
a little longer now like at least like a
week or in a bit yeah so like i'm
planning hopefully for like conor to
take me to wales
yeah we'll see if we can do that we'll
see if we can do that do that i told my
parents i was like yeah maybe maybe i'll
see you maybe maybe we'll see yeah well
it's fun because otherwise um
let's be real i'm never gonna go to
beautiful place wales be the only chance
right exactly
amazing hiking yes yeah yeah because uh
you guys are gonna be there and a lot of
other people are gonna be flying in as
well so it's gonna be like really busy
i guess two days leading up and uh even
the days that you fly in yeah honestly
i'm hyped though yeah i'm high yeah good
it's going to be like way more packs
than your last trip to england i think
because i can't why did you come to your
last trip tonight i can't remember
because we kazaki and i were already in
europe oh that's because we went to
cotton finland and we would we were just
like let's just go on a europe tour yeah
and then yeah the last stop was the uk
because we were like yeah i've never
i've never been to the uk
weirdly even though i have like a lot of
me to live there yeah it was good though
brighton was cool
we'll have we'll have uh we'll have
another lad site last night out there
yeah yeah because kevin's been like
[ __ ] messaging me every day about how
keen he is for a lads night and i'm just
like okay okay he's always keen he's
always keen for a laugh kevin when
aren't you keen for a last night let's
be honest kevin
but yeah like i mean did you get to see
a lot of london last time because i
don't know what really looks like some
brighton most of the time yeah you're in
brighton most of the time and i don't
know if you showed him any of london
that's all
london's hard to you took us to uh like
a bunch of like the oh i mean you
because like arki's parents were there
as well right yeah so you kind of like
took us to like all of the you know the
touristy places i guess luckily london
is really convenient for tourist stuff
where they like put everything really
close together yeah yeah so you can
smash it all out in a day yeah right i
don't know with london it's kind of hard
if you don't drink the only place i
remember was you took us to like the
harry potter place uh oh yeah jesus
cross whatever it is yeah the platform
nine through course yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's so
weird taking people to kings cross
because i just see it as like a train
station it is yeah it is because it's
like i think how people imagine it is
just like going to the harry potter land
in like universal studios or something
right where you have [ __ ] diagon
alley they serve you like the you know
whatever like the beer is there the
butter butter beer whatever and it's not
it's just like one one like
one like half cut out train trolley and
uh a shop and then the rest of it is
just a [ __ ] normal station it's
really busy though it is really busy
yeah it's always business luckily they
put it out of the way of the station so
if you're gonna get a train you don't
actually go near it yeah but there's a
pub behind it that sometimes i don't
know why i've been to it but it's kind
of annoying
i do miss pubs actually i can't wait to
go to the pub again yeah that's all i've
been missing that's it really yeah i
will say england has definitely upped up
their bar game since since i've uh since
i've been away yeah there's a lot more
gaming bars and
themed bars as well like uh anything's
better than the gaming bar you guys took
me too yeah yeah yeah
i went to a better one uh when i was
back last time and it was good it's just
again really expensive yeah really i
mean really expensive that's that's the
price you pay like i guess like
literally that's the price you pay for
like the really
what a
for like the upscale of just you know
themed bars anything like that because i
know we've complained about it before in
trash taste and i remember this time uh
we also celebrated a birthday as well
and uh we uh
sydney's uh sydney's uh
maid of honor
uh i say maid of honor because her maid
of honor is actually a guy
um he booked he booked her this uh
this very weird like uh not not weird
but it was a themed bar where
uh it was basically like a cowboy themed
bar but it's not just like a themed bar
it was a whole like experience like it
feels it feels like i'm undermining it
just calling it a themed bar so you know
you go in
and it's you know it's like you just you
know woke up in the south it's you know
southern america during like the deep
like when was like the cowboy [ __ ]
years i don't remember
eighteen hundreds
basically westworld
[Music]
it's basically westwood everyone's
talking in the southern accent and like
they have this you you get part you you
basically it's like bring your own booze
right and what they do is they they take
your booze whatever you choose to bring
and then they will make
whatever drinks well
is suitable with all of the booze that
you bring so you don't even buy
alcohol there you get served alcohol
there based on what you bring
and you get taken in and you know
everyone's like a cowboy and then and
then suddenly like a sheriff walks in
and then this whole there's this whole
[ __ ] storyline that's going on it's
it's like you know you're drunk yeah
yeah they they serve you like [ __ ]
moonshine down like a back alley and all
this stuff and it's this it's this
entire experience entire storyline that
you get put into that it's basically
just a bar experience it sounds like a
universal studio's ride it kind of is it
kind of is except which is they serve
you except with a lot of alcohol oh my
god i got like because because because
you bring your own booze there and you
know
there's no like
there's no like limit or there's no like
regulation for what you have to bring
there you mix a lot of [ __ ] drinks
so you end up getting very drunk and
then you wake up and you're just seeing
a bunch of [ __ ] cowboys like go out
at each other and you're like where the
[ __ ] am i i'm in the middle of london
right now it's so [ __ ] weird i gotta
tell you guys that it just sounds like a
challenge like to like bring all your
own booze right and then it's just like
what if i guarantee there's been
instances where just someone just brings
in like bottles of just like nothing but
hard liquor yeah puts it on the thing
just like make it
just
what you gonna do
see there is like a lot more choice now
in terms of like just interesting bars
bars and bar experiences it's definitely
like leveled up yeah changing a lot it
is changing well brighton is changing a
lot as well like i i
i hardly even recognize the city i grew
up in anymore just because it's
it's become like this hip modern place
and like
it's gone to the point where you know
like you know you go to some american
bars and like or some bars abroad and
you just think yeah man every every bar
needs its thing you know it's it's thing
so i went to this like re i was just
like
perusing brighton and then there was
just this bar with a zipliner on it or
zipline on it i'm just like that's
that's the weirdest gimmick i've ever
seen but
[ __ ] i want to go on it man wait a zip
liner going out of the bar or a zipliner
going into the bar a zip line going out
of the bar so basically there is a bar
which just shows in the uk any gimmick
can work if there's a bar next to it
yeah so i think what happened right is
they built the zip line on like the sea
front and so there's a zip line so you
can climb up and you can zip line down
and you can you know it's like a
dangerous combination
yeah yeah you can see the beach and
everything and then on the bottom of the
zip line there's just a bar so it's just
now the bar with the zip line on it
so people literally just zip line into
the
that's that's just the bar to be fair i
would probably go on that yeah yeah
right i would probably do that right
that's really fun
just shows like if in in the uk if you
want to come up with with a concept for
a bar just come up with a wacky concept
doesn't matter what a weird cards yeah
with alcohol yeah just put just just put
this certainly while you're on the go
just put some activity and alcohol and
british people will come to it yeah
that's yeah that's fairly accurate so
yeah spot on
yeah so
um so yeah i'm excited future comes back
i'm excited for you to guys come back to
london this time because there is a lot
more to do now so that's good i'm sure
we can plan out a lot more fun things
for you to do joey
i can't remember what i showed you last
time i took you to oh i took you to
devil's dike which is oh yeah
this is still one of the most
questionably named places i've ever been
to
it's it's basically it's just a hill
it's just a hill it's a really nice hill
that's about it
i was just laughing the entire way when
i found out what it was called and i was
like they had they really didn't think
that english is a funny language yeah
english is a very funny language that's
a nice place yeah yeah
it's about it really
i can't remember i can't remember
because you didn't stay in the uk for
that long no i don't remember i mean we
also uh
we also like drank at like brighton
beach and stuff like that but
other than that that's about it what
have you been up to joey since gone has
been gone
uh a lot of stuff i can't talk about you
oh okay yeah but uh i hung out with uh
nano the other day oh yeah i saw that
yeah yeah nice like uh she wanted to
hang out and uh we went to karaoke and
apparently she hasn't gone to karaoke in
like 15 years what well that's her life
yeah because like she sings for a job
she goes that's like she's still i mean
she's just like unavoidable yeah right
she just goes to karaoke on stage and in
the studio right and then she sang and
then we got like you know we sang a
bunch of songs and then i was like can
you sing one of your songs just jokingly
yeah yeah because you know she has her
songs on karaoke so it's like you have
to seize that opportunity of course of
course and she's like i've never sung my
own songs at karaoke before and so i
thought that was going to be like a no
yeah that was like a nice way of her
saying no she then proceeds to put in
like literally every song
i got a concert yeah amazing i basically
just got a free concert maybe no one
asked her before
no one had the
she's like i've been waiting for someone
to ask me this my entire life joey the
audacity of this guy to ask
no but she was really [ __ ] cool and
like we got to hang out and like we're
going to hang out a lot more um yeah
other than that i've just been like
yeah every day i've just been like
hanging out with someone different nice
yeah that's always funny yeah just going
out and uh yeah it's been good it's uh
being sociable again and you know after
the pandemic has been really nice yeah
right yeah
have you had a chance to hang out with
archie a lot because there's a lot of
things we can't talk about but one thing
i will say is that joey didn't get to
see a lot of hockey last month no i
think i saw her for like a week
maybe so uh she was like you know yeah
let's hang out a little more and i was
like yeah
we should probably do that
i did i did though i did
we hung out a lot um like we we go like
uh like kind of like once a week dates
just to like you know nearby places like
hanging out and stuff
and uh yeah it's really good um oh yeah
i've i've discovered like
a lot
of toka in this past week i think really
just because i've been going out to like
all sorts of different places with all
sorts of different people so it's like
you know there's like i was in shibuya
just yesterday for uh my friend luke's
birthday
and like we went to like all these new
places like i've never been before like
we were in like areas of shibuya where i
was like oh this is she was just excited
and it's just so weird that like tokyo's
is one of those places where it's like
it's everything is just so like
tight-knit and like kind of hidden that
there are just entire areas of cities
you've probably never seen before yeah
yeah and it's just like oh oh this place
exists and this is kind of cool yeah my
google maps is [ __ ] because i've saved
so many restaurants and bars i like yeah
yeah i
like
none of them mean anything now because i
don't know which one is what you
literally have to [ __ ] yeah when i'm
trying to remember a bar i'm like
there's no search function so i'm
literally i'm like i think it was this
area and i'm just checking all my hearts
in that area yeah yeah and i'm like okay
great it's none of the [ __ ] these
great yeah i'm [ __ ]
there's no way to categorize i've
actually started doing that now because
i didn't do that before but because when
you go to so many different places and
you're trying to recall that one place
in tokyo right right it's like the
hardest [ __ ] city because like in
most other cities you can be like what
is this bar and you like type in the
description of the bar you're like great
there's only one bar in this area it's
like five minutes away you type in like
the vague description in like tokyo and
like seven different bars pop up you're
like it was one of these i think i don't
even know if i'm describing it right you
know it's great because like you know
like when uh emily and dardis just moved
here it's like all right what food do
you want i have i have a i have a thing
for that yeah what bond what kind of bar
vibe do you want all right i've got like
three of each kind yeah oh we're in this
area okay we'll go to this one i have
the i have a thing like i've saved like
everything so i've got every kind of
restaurant every kind of vibe you'd want
yeah so i've got i've got a bunch so
it's fantastic but like it's become so
extensive now that you're just like okay
so you're going for a specific vibe yeah
specific food i know like eight places
yeah yeah which one of these eight
places do you want yeah and it's like
how expensive do you want okay yeah
now do you want to be like five minute
walk from the station town orphan
station okay we're gonna go this bar
afterwards though is that okay with you
yeah it's like all right okay okay i'm
still trying to find more as well yeah
so many places i'll never i'm never
gonna see them all yeah honestly yeah
like even just like in shibuya like
there's just so many places to just eat
or drink out they're like
you could go out every night to like a
bar yeah like somewhere different in
just in shibuya and it'll probably take
you like years yeah like one one thing i
definitely noticed going back to the uk
for two weeks that i did is that i've
definitely taken for granted how easy it
is to find somewhere to stay out late in
japan i've like forgotten about that in
um in the uk because it's 12. yeah yeah
yeah it's impossible yeah he hits 12 and
like every bar closes every pub closes
so the only place that's like that you
can viably go to basically is
a uh is a club most of the time i don't
want to go clubbing you know i don't i
don't want to go to club i want to
continue the conversation i'm having so
i've definitely gotten used to in japan
you hit up like the karaoke or there's
this one bar that's open till like 4 a.m
or there's so many places open until
late and i've forgotten that in the uk
he hits 12 and you like try to google
where the next place to go to is and
there's nothing there is just nothing
you just come out blank you're like well
[ __ ] we gotta keep this going somehow
right and uh there's just no options
available unfortunately uk sucks for
that i do remember that yeah every every
night at 12 it's like all right [ __ ] we
have to really look to find a place yeah
it's just like someone went to like the
the power bank it just went
yeah everything just goes down like an
apocalypse well on sundays like shop
shut like 4 p.m what well like just like
supermarkets yeah
really yeah or some places just don't
even open oh i mean like i get the don't
even open but like what's the point of
like being open for like five hours i
think i think i think london has laws of
like on sunday a shopkin
remain open for x amount of hours so
they choose like the busiest hours from
like 10 till last oh i see i can't
remember what the exact hours were i
know at least where where i lived in
london it was that rule yeah so all the
shops shot and opened at the same time
on sundays yeah yeah i mean it's it's
kind of been like that right now like
with uh it being golden week in japan
yeah yeah and like when i was hanging
out with nana like we were trying to
find like a lunch place yeah and it's
either it's either it's closed during
golden week right or it's got like 200
capacity yeah yeah if you come to japan
try and avoid this period because uh
hotels and flights and everything is
like oh my god i saw like pictures of
like
like hunted at the airport oh god this
week it is a nightmare yeah because it's
basically the only week off that most
working japanese people have like where
they have a full week off yeah so they
all travel they all go to hotels so yeah
try and avoid this week if you come to
japan yeah because it's it's it's rams
it is it's the week where every manga
chapter takes a week off yeah that's how
you know that's how i remember is that
is that actually that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah because i was just
like i was i remember like you know i
remember growing up and being like man
naruto one piece and bleach are taking a
break on like the same week what's going
on what's going i need to know what's
happening man that's how manga readers
tell the time they're like oh oda's
taking a week off it must be gold
yeah because it's not only like that
bars close as well like i forget you
know combini's everything here so if you
need access to alcohol if you're going
brandon mate's house whatever you've
always got the company but like you want
to go to a tescos or a sainsburys or
something you better hope that you plan
ahead and you get it before like 11
which is yeah some places close at 11
and that's like the latest at some
places closing it's just like double the
price of the alcohol because you're a
corner store that's shitty and they make
all their money from up charging alcohol
yeah but even like there are some corner
stores you go to especially in london
where you know it's open but they don't
serve alcohol past 12 months so it's
it's it's like well [ __ ] man
you you literally have no options so but
i discovered that the other day when i
was like coming home late and it was
like you know last train and stuff and i
was like oh man feeling a bit hungry
like might just like pop over to a
mcdonald's just do a quick little maccas
run before i yeah
and it was like one a.m right and the
mcdonald's was still open i was like oh
sick amazing let's go in so i walk in
and the guy is like dorinku only
and i was like
who the [ __ ] is walking into a
mcdonald's to get a drink look i'll
close the sign for you bro
yeah like literally why you walk down
dude shut it down it's like i could just
go to a corn beanie
bro who's going who's going to
mcdonald's being like um one sprite
brilliant
at 1am as well right here like
they're making this from like the drinks
to like warren staying open only for
drinks i mean i i thought it was a bit
weird being like oh okay it's still open
but there's no one in here right now
now i know so you don't know your target
audience if you're at 1am and you're
serving drinks only
like there isn't like a special drink
that's only served at mcdonald's you
know yeah
there's only one reason i'm going to
mcdonald's at 1am it's a smash of
[ __ ] yeah it's like give me a [ __ ]
burger yeah you want to smash your
burger smashing a burger or like
ordering those 20 nugs which you would
never order except at 1am at a
mcdonald's like i'm not here to smash an
orange juice at a mcdonald's at 1am like
i can do that anywhere
i always get the milk
i only exclusively
donald's milk i get there for milk
that's it
much either i've kind of just been
working
i went to
uh behind barbecue a bunch that was fun
was chill nice it was nice it was
raining though how's how's the weather
been here i was like i guess i was good
literally you answered my question as i
was processing what i was going to say
so this place i stayed at like a place
outside where you could still barbecue
even if it was raining it was like
covered right that was fun and it was
yeah it was fun i liked it it's a good
time for barbie right now yeah yeah it's
like just warming up yeah so that was
chill got to do that that was fun i just
smelled of smoke three days it was fun
and then we had like a bonfire and then
it was very fun because you just keep
adding yeah we just chop our own wood as
well that was fun oh there's camping
vibes yeah yeah
because it would have did you have like
an axe and everything it was a hammer
and there was like a thing where you put
the log on and it was like like a metal
thing like this oh nice smack it into it
oh cool i could just hear like the i
don't know like the
the dwarf music from lord of the rings
in my head just like where i was like
smacking away just like bring me another
log
as you were chopping in your beard just
extensions
[Applause]
one of those like lumberjacks yeah
i was like yeah this is what it's all
about you're bringing my logs over like
this i'm like all in the fire we go
the the red and black checkered shirt
you know
this is so fun i don't know why chopping
wood was so fun your hair just turns red
yeah
and bought a bunch of
food and barbecued it and i bought way
too much food because it's really hard
to eat at all i mean it is costco i know
i know so much food but it was so
[ __ ] good it's so delicious
barbecuing yeah i love bbq how long were
you there for uh like three days so
pretty chill pretty chill it's nice to
relax get away yeah and just uh chill
for a bit before i guess i'm gonna go
away again but it's because like this
next
two three weeks just all work
so
and then going to the uk yeah with a
little bit of work
yeah wedding and stuff i'm trying to
like
pack as much as i can before i fly back
because it's definitely like i was like
yeah i'm go i can work at home i have
like i have like a dedicated office
where i can work and stuff if i need to
but it's just something about being out
of japan my body's just like you are in
holiday mode now yeah you do why do you
need to work people are out people who
want to see like i'm telling myself i'll
be like i'll have a bit of time in the
uk to like do some stuff yeah i could
probably just like sneak in i know
though the moment i get there i was just
like yeah so pop pop i wanna i wanna
live stream but i just feel like i'm
gonna be stream sniped into oblivion in
london
if i'm drinking at a pub yeah yeah
that'd be fun though trash taste is
definitely like
it's definitely changed things for me in
the uk in terms of yeah i was about to
ask like how much were you like
recognized in the uk uh i was compared
to before
a lot
like the [ __ ] like at this wedding i
went to the bartender was a fan of trash
taste right
no way
[Laughter]
to like giving him like a free drink
because because she was like you
recognize him but you don't recognize me
how dare you how dare you it's not
she's literally been on the show one
time and she's like i'm the one who's on
track you know who i am i am getting
married to him actually
she was also very intoxicated at this
time as we all were but um
no but uh yeah like because brighton has
become like i guess youtuber city they
influence the city like it's so weird
like i can't like sometimes i'll just be
sitting at my local pub um which i won't
say but it is my local pub so it is
within the vicinity which in which i
live um and it's very like nervous
whenever nerve-wracking whenever like i
get recognized there because
one it's weird to go to like the pub
that you grew up in and that you always
went to and you know you uh you grew up
there um and now you go there and
sometimes the odd person just recognizes
you from trash taste and it's always
trash taste it's all like yeah it's it's
all trash taste so
um sometimes like people recognize me
even though i go like i got the mask on
when i'm like walking in brighton um
it's it's super super surreal because
obviously it's the place i grew up in
and now it's like it's become this
really hip
happening influencer city you know um
basically the la of uk when it comes to
youtube yeah yeah yeah yeah definitely
definitely so there's like there's
actually like i think i got recognized
more in brighton per se than i did in
london because london's like a bit more
spread out it's a bit more like
dispersed you know i do get recognized
the odd place in london but definitely
like in brighton it's it's way more
concentrated like whenever i go to the
city center it's you know and there's
normally like one or two people that
recognizes me from trash tastes yeah
yeah that's cool probably be the same
for you guys as well
maybe yeah
really well though
yeah it's going to be interesting
because like we haven't really like you
know since trash day started we haven't
really like had that yet right yeah it's
like you know the borders have been
closed here so like not as many
foreigners coming to japan i mean a
little more recently i'd say i mean i've
been like i i don't know if you've
noticed but like the past like month or
so i've been like oh yeah i got
recognized white people
twice in one day the other day oh really
yeah yeah i've noticed there's like a
lot more people now shinjuku oh okay
well that makes sense yeah yeah yeah so
that was like i was like well that's
weird it's happening a lot more yeah
because people are coming in now like
they've uh made it a lot easier to uh
get in the country uh at least my
experience was uh this time i spent an
hour and an hour and a half in the
airport as opposed to four hours so it's
nice yeah which is nice
they've like uh the first thing i
noticed is that they removed the [ __ ]
cattle tag that they that they like give
everyone so i didn't feel like livestock
which was a nice positive yeah i can't
imagine if you like you're waiting for
years to come in you know your work visa
finally the [ __ ] country opens and
the first thing they do is like tag you
like brand new like [ __ ] brandy you
know
so you know
thank god they've removed that system
yeah everything's just a lot more
streamlined now um and i mean it's like
it's a lot easier traveling outside of
the country as well i mean england i
didn't even need to get tested or
give like a vaccine certificate or
anything it's just it's just back to
normal right
god bless the queen
[Laughter]
it's kind of crazy yeah oh yeah
hopefully it lasts because like the one
thing i'm really [ __ ] worried about
is you know while we're overseas like
say god's wedding and then they'll just
like
discovered a new strain guys
let's go yeah even if they do people
like no yeah
i don't think so
well the one thing that i am i don't
know if i'm looking forward to or
dreading is the next convention we guys
we we go to yeah we can't announce what
it is yet yeah yeah we are going to
conventions we
are going to several conventions but
like i remember what it was like before
trash taste i can't imagine what going
to a convention is going to be like
confluence
was always a thing you know and now it's
like confluent steroids is a thing now
yeah one one thing we've definitely like
we've definitely had to
plan around
that i've never we've never needed to do
before in conventions is uh uh like
planning what we're doing and the events
we're going to is that technically we
are now a fire hazard you know yeah
we are now a fire hazard uh so
that's something that i never had to
think about before yeah people are
asking like do you want security and i'm
like i feel so weird yeah yeah
i do i already want a guy just following
me around but then yeah i guess i don't
want to get hurt but i mean it feels
weird i don't know yeah it does it
definitely feels weird because it's
definitely a different kind of planning
than any like than any of the
conventions i've been to before um
because like i've always seen like you
know there's been like a couple of big
guests at like conventions i've been to
right that have security guards and
security and i was just like
look at this
[Applause]
and i don't know how to feel about that
because like i don't want to be like
guys i i don't i don't need all this
extra [ __ ] come on guys come on guys i'm
just i'm just a guy i'm just a guy but
at the same time like i'm like
especially being back this time being
like i can't even walk down my local
streets how's it going to be where all
of the weebs and all of the people
without interested in your content um
and your you know and
your content field are going to be
concentrated in one place and i'm just
like that's uh pretty scary no i think
about it i've never been cool though
it's going to be really cool i haven't
seen it in a while i'm excited to see
what it is yeah yeah yeah the last fan
meetup i had i can't remember it's quite
there's a decent amount of people who
showed up to it so yeah i don't even
know if i can even do a fan meetup this
time yeah yeah i was i was i was talking
to allen and he was just like yeah
remember when you used to do like
unofficial fan meetups yeah i don't
think that's happening this time and i'm
just like yeah because it is it is a
fire hazard or like that has to be taken
into account when we do any kind of
meetups now like how are we gonna
arrange people who come to see us and
are we blocking anything that could
potentially be a health and safety
hazard it sucks though because i missed
this off the convention people yeah yeah
yeah yeah it sucks because i i used to
do like those kinds of like casual fan
meetups every now and then with aki and
like i missed that [ __ ] i missed it it's
like it's because it's so chill yeah
because it's like you know you just like
you just tweeted out being like hey
we're going to be here for a couple of
hours if you want to hang out just come
hang out and it's usually like you know
like
50 people max and that's like a sizeable
amount of to be like yeah okay you know
what this is yeah this is kind of cheap
you can talk to people yeah
you can talk to everyone you can have a
conversation yeah
where people have come from and yeah
yeah i've met like so many cool people
through that and now it's just sucks
that like yeah it's a fire hazard now
and now it's an indian wedding
so now here's the strat if you see me
outside the grenadine yes the better
that you can talk to me yeah yeah yeah
exactly well but that's like that's like
playing gotcha
sorry you mentioned because i don't
leave my room but maybe if you do we can
talk a little bit unless i'm in a rush
then i'll be like sorry
because then it's always that it's
always that instance of like if someone
recognizes you in those kinds of like
outside convention settings yeah all it
takes is for one person to be like oh my
god connor for everyone that just yeah
[ __ ] whip their heads around and then
a crowd gets full yeah yeah yeah i
conventions from this crowd people
normally want to see what the crowd's
about yeah yeah
so
yeah so i remember the worst i saw it
before was you at the singaporean
convention where i it was it was like
traveling next to [ __ ] justin bieber
you know
like i we we had like this that was
pretty good we had like panels to go to
and i remember it was just like you
could not take two steps without being
stopped yeah and uh that was the first
time i had to get security yeah oh wow
and i was like did you get security yeah
i had to because the con was literally
like if you keep going you're gonna be a
fire hazard yeah yeah and so i was like
this is cool but also really [ __ ]
weird yeah uh fire hazard but just
because you're like blocking walkways or
something it's not not like it's a big
deal but like if you if it's not like
someone's there with a [ __ ] match but
like people are stopping right so if you
if you just stop in a hallway or
something it's technically a fire hazard
yeah like a lot of the venues can be
like punished if that like gets yeah
around that's happening you know yeah 10
people stop that's fine that's
manageable 50 people stop you know
you're kind of
you're kind of you know getting in the
way of people if like 100 200 people
stop then you are stopping the flow of
people walking about you know causing
literal i was going to call it human
traffic
like is there like a world you are human
trafficking
you are human trafficking right now
like i don't know what the
word is or the term is but it's
basically human trafficking
yeah a human trafficking job
i went to a convention i think you went
to the same one or an image in case you
get annoyed um that apparent one year
they had uh markiplier at the convention
yeah and apparently this is like the
first convention the markiplier ever did
yeah and uh i they spoke about this like
it was like the zombie apocalypse dude
because apparently right what happened
was is that you know uh i think some did
jacksepticeye go to
uh one of the years i think i remember
it was a really big big [ __ ] deal and
the convention like runners didn't like
they knew youtube and they knew that it
was like a big deal but they didn't
quite understand yeah like how big of a
deal it was so they were like woefully
unprepared yeah for like uh like
markiplier's audience
and apparently they were just like it
was like insane like the security
barriers they didn't like have anything
really yeah and so like apparently it
was like stampedes like people were just
getting like hurt and they had like one
security guy for like a thousand people
when only a hundred people should have
turned up and they didn't plan you know
and they had because they had like they
paid i don't know god god knows amount
of money for that one extra and that one
marvel movie and they were like well
he's a big deal so it's kind of like
they just kind of didn't get it and they
talked about absolute nightmares yeah
they talked about it as if it was like a
scene ripped straight out of like like
like
like
like
like
or something yeah like dead rising it's
just like yeah it was insane apparently
but like
every single time anything would come up
they'd be like the event that shall not
be named it's such a disaster like
trying to manage this that they they the
convention i they think that their
reasoning was that they like banned
him from coming back and that's yeah i
was like something was your problem
though yeah yeah definitely i don't know
i can't remember exactly how dare you be
too popular yeah right our convention i
i think that that's something like that
they it was really like they had [ __ ]
up massively and not considered well i
think you know it's it's events like
this that have
thankfully made
events and people and not just events
but also like influencers themselves uh
no
i know i know i hate the word i hate
but like we're like you know people like
us
we are not the same we don't like those
no no no because like the reason i talk
about like you know youtubers or you
know
you know
whatever is that we came we came from
like you know we all came from the same
place and we don't want to
we don't want to feel like we you know
we don't need security we don't need to
worry about this we're like we're like
we're like the man of the people you
know but like at the same time there's
been enough incidents like the
markiplier thing like tanacon you know
like a lot there's been enough other
influencers who have set the president
to be like things can go really really
[ __ ] wrong if you don't plan [ __ ] out
because you we know that you want to be
seen as you know the casual person you
know you you know the same you know the
same as everyone else but you do have a
massive audience and you need to like
it's gotten to the point where a lot of
people need to think about how do they
manage the audience they have irl
because you see a number you see a
number on your youtube and you're just
like that's ten thousand people that's a
hundred thousand people it's it's just a
number but when you translate that
number even if it's just like a tenth of
the number you see on your youtube
channel
to real
clue l i don't know what's going on
situation because like normally like
with how trash chase has grown over like
the past few years normally we'd like
we'd get to like ramp up the experience
to be like okay guys i think we're
reaching that point where we need to
kind of start thinking about this kind
of stuff think about that but because
it's just been two years of us talking
in japan and we have no idea what it's
going to be like when we like i guess
return to the rest of the world and
conventions and stuff like that i'm
we're just playing a guessing game a lot
of the time and like what we're going to
need and how we're going to manage it
last time i went to ax i could like
easily walk through it all and there was
like maybe like i don't know 50 50
chance that i would someone would
recognize me yeah and that was when i
had like what 400 000 subs or something
yeah yeah
so and that was before trashes obviously
yeah so that's i don't know what it's
gonna be like now i mean who knows yeah
dude yeah not excited for it
i'm excited i'm excited about dreading
yeah i'm like oh god i don't want to
cause any problems it's like it's like
equal i don't meet everyone i want to
say hi to you guys excitement equal
amounts terrifying yeah yeah say say me
i'm i'm nervous in both ways i'm like
i'm excited to go experience conventions
and just go see the vibe and everything
again i'm scared to see
how things have changed after uh after
last year mourning the loss of my weird
convention stories probably now you know
i i don't get to stay in random discord
airbnbs that when i met people online
yeah that's not gonna happen anymore
that sucks
that was fun fun fun stories
weird moments in my life he will
reminisce as he sits in his five-star
hotel
i'm i'm just like you for real
you know he doesn't miss that conical is
just like give me the [ __ ] five-star
hotel
right now
it's fun but also it's like god damn i
that was that was no way to live
like damn did you live like this
i think i got all my really stupid ideas
out of my head and now i'm trying to be
more sensible and take care of myself
yeah
it's time to adult now
this episode is sponsored by harry's
boys you know i've been using harry's
for a very long time yes you have the
only razor i trust near my beautiful
boyish young face become part of your
routine it's become part of my daily
routine because it's the only blade that
i trust that'll give me the best shave
possible well then you'll be happy to
know connor and audience that harry's is
giving their best offer to you guys get
out right now get out of it that's right
first time harry's customers can redeem
a starter set for just three dollar
reduced three dollars if you go to
harry's dot com slash trash taste that
includes a five blade cartridge a
weighted handle foamy shave gel and a
travel cover to protect your blades on
the go a 13 value for just what three
dollars harry's has the highest customer
satisfaction in the shaving industry i
can concur and they're still offering a
no risk trial don't like your shave no
worries it's on them so what are you
doing get the new look with the same
incredible offer there's never really
been a better time to give harry's a try
just go to harris.com trash taste to get
your starter set for just three dollars
that's harry's dot com slash trash taste
back to the episode okay well i guess uh
we've literally got approval from maylin
that we can announce actually what are
we announcing one where uh one place
that we're going is going to be anime
expo
that should have been the obvious one i
i feel like us announcing anime expo is
just like well of course of course
i also eat food
yes i am an anime youtuber
no one knew if it was even happening
this year yeah yeah i mean i certainly
got [ __ ] bombarded by my twitch chat
being like you got anywhere
you're gonna actually see us all right
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know what else we got hopefully
a bunch of like cool things planned
nothing announced can we announce the
rest of the [ __ ] that we're doing
not sure yet we do have something
special some cool stuff happening yeah
yeah we do have it's not just gonna be
us turning up at ax we do have some cool
stuff planned for ax as well
we'll uh we'll see you there yeah yeah
you see me around say hi uh buy me a
drink um
don't don't say that you're gonna be
like 200 you're gonna be like
intoxicated
what am i going to do with all these
drinks
don't bring me a drink if you're in a
bar then you can find it's going to just
be like a line of like to the sea dog va
yeah
just like he has a drink other than
here's a drink like an offering
please don't bring me food it is an
absolute nightmare to try and carry
around with me you don't want food don't
bring me food yes yeah yeah i'm also fat
enough i don't need any more yeah if you
do if you do see me outside of the
convention buy me a drink as well uh as
long as i'm not like carrying five
drinks at the time i buy you drinks the
only food i will accept however is
flaming hot cheetos you can you can
bring me as much
no no no no no no because they'll
everyone will bring one don't say that
yeah that's exactly what i want okay
just give it to me that's a joey just
give it to me
his hotel is gonna be a [ __ ] hot
cheeto landfill dude
i'm just gonna i'm gonna just open the
window and just like throwing [ __ ]
cheetos to the crowd
you get some cheetos
when was the last day x we went to three
years ago yeah it was it was literally
the last convention
because it was like one of my it's
always my favorite conventions to go to
yeah yeah so because it was good to meet
everyone it's not just a convention it's
basically just like yeah it's an
attitude of meet up it's it isn't any
change
the british people get to see the
american people pretty much yeah because
we're all not american yeah yeah i
wonder how many people are going to go
there this year in terms of yeah other
content creators and stuff like that
call to action well if if you're any
content creators go into ax hit us up
whatever see you there yeah
we'll be in l.a as well
i wonder if we're gonna have the like
the
annual annietuber meetup because like
did you guys go to that last year last
time i can't remember i did not because
there was like it was the last one not
the one at the bowling alley
there was one other bowling alley yeah
oh no that's that's the other the
funniest
party huh do you want to explain what
this is yeah so every every when did it
even start i don't remember i can't
remember i think it's like five six
years ago or something but like as long
as i've been ax there's always been one
but there's there's always been like
this like unofficial like anituber
meetup like thing where basically
uh it used to just be done like outside
of the the convention hall like in that
uh yeah open area where all the cosplays
are
and it's just like it's like it doesn't
matter how big or small of an attitude
you are you can just come to this event
you know kind of meet everyone because
like at the end of the day like
especially like five six years ago the
energy community was so [ __ ] small
right yeah so you know there'd be like
30 people yeah yeah yeah
the last one i went to though there was
like a hundred people i was like oh
it's getting a bit big yeah i was
getting bigger now because that one was
like all right people were asking for
invites and then people were asking them
for invites yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
there were people there definitely
weren't making youtube videos yeah
people just like showed up they were
just showing up because they knew it
would be there yeah exactly
it was like ah
i don't know yeah yeah i don't know how
it's going to work nowadays but there's
normally like one of like there's
normally like one annie cheaper or
something who has just rented out a
house and that that's that's just now
become like the unofficial annie tube
meetup pretty much well they just ran
out of house and they just invite a
bunch of people yeah you know that one
was chill that that one was that one
yeah but yeah the one the last time we
did one like outside of the convention
was like five years ago i think and
there was like maybe
50 60 people there obviously way too
many people like actually like you know
meet yeah and get to know personally but
like yeah i i miss those like you know i
met like a lot of like really cool and
youtubers and then i met you i met john
for the first time surprise patchwolf
there love seeing john the first time
he was the crowd favorite that year
because he'd never been to a convention
and never shown his face
so everyone was like yo surprise let's
go dude yeah i'm also obviously chill
dude absolutely
absolute chad
he's the mega child of anachu
in terms of looks
man's got a [ __ ] jawline and a half
dude
dude i'm hyped man i'm really excited to
go to conventions i think not being able
to see the viewers for a long time has
like made my brain go too youtubery i
got a youtube brain
it's all numbers for me it's all numbers
dude
it doesn't mean anything to me i haven't
seen anyone this is the date of my house
i just stayed in japan even more
isolated yeah yeah i just want to be
drinking at a bar and then someone
strikes up a conversation be like oh i
love your stuff and we just have like a
nice chill conversation that's like some
of my favorite fan interactions because
as much as i want to have like the
longer like conversations where people
come to meetups it you know it's like
yeah you're in like indian wedding like
headspace where she's like you know you
you have a you know if you're lucky like
a few minutes with with everyone but
yeah when you're just chilling and that
random guy recognizes you a random girl
you're just having like a nice
conversation you're just like ah i
remember why i started what i'm doing
right now moments like this man i
weirdly have a lot of those though in
japan i think because like you go you
don't get recognized as often in japan
like especially nowadays right so like
the one person who does find you on the
street you actually you know as long as
you're not in a rush like you actually
have like you know at least me anyway i
have like a you know at least like a
three or four minute conversation being
like oh you know what are you doing here
like yeah all that kind of stuff and
like those are the best yeah those are
the best
well in japan it's like different
because right now no one here is a
tourist right so everyone here is like
doing something or has like an
interesting story
or is like working here or something
like that and lots of students now lots
of students now there is lots of lots of
students now i don't know because like
when did they start letting people in
again uh
a month ago like a month ago yeah i mean
i've noticed i mean i've barely been in
japan for the last
month like how's it been for you guys i
did a stream recently and i got stream
sniped a lot more than last time right i
think that that was that was interesting
yeah yeah like it's it's definitely gone
to the point now where again like i've
just noticed there's like oh there's a
lot more foreigners now and then yeah i
just remember like oh yeah there's just
a lot more students now and then
obviously you know you have more of a
chance to get recognized like i was in
like [ __ ] middle of nowhere like the
other week
you know outside of tokyo yeah and there
was just like two random dudes who just
like recognized me and i was just like
this is this like in my head i was like
this is weird but then i was like no
this is what it used to be like yeah
yeah so now it's so now it's just this
like weird like
kind of whiplash of being like oh [ __ ]
we're like slowly going back to normal
finally the world the world is here
yeah because you're planning to go back
to australia this year as well aren't
you yeah yeah i'm gonna go see my family
for the first time in three years oh my
gosh
well i mean like the trip to the uk uh
for your wedding is the first time i'm
gonna be overseas in three years paul
yeah oh yeah cause the last time you
attempted to go overseas you got
deported
and you've been waiting three years
since then yeah my last that's like ptsd
now yeah the last time i went on an
international flight i got deported so
that's a cool story that's a cool story
it's cool sorry to tell the kids but
like um yeah yeah i'm going down to like
yeah see my family and mates and stuff
like that so that's going to be
very weird yeah just like seeing the
city i grew up in like completely change
because my sister was saying that like
yeah this it's completely changed in the
past three years i'm like it's gonna be
weird it didn't it it it was very weird
going back to my home city and just
seeing it completely changed as well but
even just seeing london slowly changing
for the skyline of london there's loads
more skyscrapers now yeah yeah yeah
there's like two and now there's like
tons more things that's crazy yeah i
wonder how it managed to not get them
for so long then it's very strange but
now i'm going to be so scared like or
what you experienced of just like being
at like a place that's very like local
and familiar to me yeah like if i go to
like my local mall i'm just going to be
like no one recognize me please not here
don't don't follow me home yeah yeah
yeah that's what that's that's what i
was watching yeah yeah
god be like come on my house for some
tea
meet my parents throw some crumpets and
biscuits come on come on
yeah i mean london's become very bougie
i like i called an uber like it was like
my first uber in london yeah and uh
[ __ ] tesla shows up
and i was just like this is an uber
right i just called an uber yeah a
[ __ ] tesla shows up and like i i'd
never ridden in a tesla before right uh
have you guys ever ridden in a tesla
yeah i haven't oh yeah so like i didn't
know how they worked because the first
thing you normally go when you go to a
car is you go and you pour the handle
right so i go up to this tesla
and there's no handle it's it's
literally just like it's literally kind
of like a flat kind of handle police
yeah animal place so i didn't know you
were meant to like just push it in and
the handle comes out i was just like i
was like daddy elon has designed some
like [ __ ] futuristic like travel to
mars [ __ ]
[ __ ] stuff it's probably electric so
i'm standing there in front of the tesla
like thinking it's like an automatic
door going
so i'm like uh did he have to uh yeah he
actually had to like come out just like
tell me just just to like push the
handle in i just imagine can't just be
like open
open
daddy elon please where is it
was it fun though riding on a tesla it
was very fun yeah it was uh it's a toy
it's like it's like a toy because it's
like so futuristic really it is it is
i'm excited yeah it was it was a weird
like seeing
you know seeing like the pad at the
front just completely track everyone
yeah all the cars but like when it came
to pedestrians it was just like [ __ ]
freaking the [ __ ] out because there's so
many people in london
so it would you know just just seeing it
like just like humans appeared and
disappeared and like this dog was a dog
was a human then it wasn't and but like
it was it was very cool it is very much
a toy um i know like um our mate's
parents own owns one as well
never shuts up about it never shuts up
about it he drives it and he's like oh
my mom bought it though he doesn't
mention that he says my tesla ah tesla
oh tesla
yeah because uh he took you on plenty of
uh yeah
yeah yeah i got [ __ ] in the car i'll
tell you about that remember that you're
you know
the tesla had been sitting there all day
i had the window down yeah
and uh i can't remember exactly what
happened but it was like we were driving
along this really country road
and then
i don't know i remember what happened
we're driving along this country road
it's kind of dirt road it's you know
it's not the cleanest way we're going
and then he's trying to show off that it
can go like naught to 60 and like you
know as every car owner does they have
to prove that the car is fast yeah as if
normal cars don't go fast
so we're going fast and as he speeds up
there's like uh like i don't know if
it's a comp like a harvester or
something plowing the fields next to us
i no it's like the machine that spreads
manure oh okay yeah so as it's spreading
it we're going by and then before i know
i'm like chilling like this in the car
and then suddenly just a [ __ ] wave of
manure starts hitting my face in the car
and it's
launched into this tesla
and then
everyone is doing that thing of course
like
oh god oh god ah and then there's just
[ __ ] everywhere it is tesla and he just
got it cleaned like a white it's like
white seats as well it's like
white seed tesla and the inside is pure
white absolutely like [ __ ] white
you should never have your interior this
color for this reason you know and so
there's just oh god and so the entire
car journey it just smells of cow [ __ ]
it just absolutely reeks of cow [ __ ] and
he's freaking out because it's his
parents tesla and he's borrowing it so
he's like he's like
oh what am i gonna do oh
it's like freaking out yeah i'm like
don't worry we're gonna clean up
and there's like
like chunks like this big of manure in
the car
and it's just it's and the smell is just
everywhere oh my god so we go into that
we go into like a pizza express
afterwards we just stink of [ __ ] and
we're just eating pizza
and then i think he goes to get it they
must have been so confused because like
the people working there is just like a
bunch of dudes just smelling like [ __ ]
eating pizza and they're like oh man
they [ __ ] live like this meanwhile
they head back into this yeah
what the [ __ ]
so i think he got it cleaned like the
next day or the day off because he was
so angry yeah
i remember him like
him like building up that he's like oh
my god my parents let me borrow the
tesla guys i'm driving the tesla i'm
driving the tesla and it was just like
this this massive event in our friend
group that like eugene's coming in a
[ __ ] tesla damn day after connor's
like guys i got [ __ ] eugene's tesla
yes we're going to country road i'm the
kind of guy i don't know why i don't
know what why people want to do this but
i just want to put my arm like this yeah
of course of course
and so yeah then uh obviously i couldn't
have predicted that a bunch of manure is
going to fly on the carpet yeah
i did
that's a funny story
i
remember just like feeling bad for
eugene but also
laughing very very hard
i was covered in [ __ ] but it was so
funny at his anger that his tesla was
covered in [ __ ] yeah he kind of
cancelled out being covered it was it
was worse i wasn't too bothered about
being covered in [ __ ] yeah
yeah it was good
um i also oh recently i watched
yesterday in fact this is good timing i
watched the new doctor strange movie oh
how is it very mid
actually it's probably one of the most
boring movies i've watched in a long
time really oh wow okay because i heard
like a lot of good things about it i'm
sad i was really excited for it i
um watch it make your own mind up i also
watched it in dolby atmos and i was way
too close to the front and i really
regret it because some of that [ __ ]
sound effects there's this one sound
effect in the start where like he
summons like a saw and i swear to god
and he punctured my ear this this sore
sound
but yeah it was weird it was all over
the place the thing that i don't like
about doctor strange um i don't know if
anyone else feels this way
i don't know what the [ __ ] his powers
are like it's just like whatever he
needs to do yeah yeah it's just like
he's like all right
he does the circle okay i'll do a circle
uh then now i summon a a monster and now
i summon a boat and it's like
i don't know what the [ __ ] your
abilities are like i i i don't know no
one has ever taught and there is never a
scene where he's learning these powers
yeah like individual specialists i've
always just how does this work i've
always just said like he he's his power
is kind of like the metronome move in
pokemon you know where it's just like he
just waggles his fingers and something
happens you know it's like i i don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on and the
entire movie feels like when you're kids
with you know when you're when you're
like eight years old and you pretend
like you have like a magic fight with
your
your childhood friend you're like yeah
and i summoned this oh no i i do this oh
i drew this back that's what the whole
movie felt like it was just it's not
just a jojo fight yeah but like at least
jojo there's some tense to it there's
some intensity yeah this entire fight
was like all right well of course she's
gonna win and then it's just this yeah
there's just so there's just like what
what the [ __ ] is this movie i don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on it's so stupid
this entire movie was just like all
right now this i know this
and it's like what is happening yeah i
heard from like like comic book fans
like dr strange is meant to be like one
of the most powerful beings in like the
avengers or whatever right and they've
just like completely nerfed him in the
mcu or something like that um because i
don't have no idea what the [ __ ] his
ability is apart from just like
summoning uh something the circle thing
and something the teleport
basically it's just paul right
maybe he just supports maybe maybe the
maybe the character in the comics is
interesting but like i was so [ __ ]
bored in this movie yeah i was like and
then halfway through there they because
it's the multiverse and they introduce
other marvel characters from other
marvel and then it's supposed to be like
i guess just comic book boner moments
where i'm just supposed to be like
impressed that
uh they included that scene
from the x-men turned up yeah i don't
give a [ __ ] why is i i'm not impressed
by this like there's just a moment where
like he'll come in and then the music
will play the stereotypical oh it's a
character you're supposed to know
and then it's like all right cool and
now and then he's dead and then it's
like all right okay
what is happening dude
is it because like you just haven't
watched many mcu movies i've watched a
lot of them i've watched a lot of them
and this was the only one like i haven't
watched was eternals because i heard it
was complete doo-doo yeah and
uh
captain marvel i didn't watch because i
heard it was really bad yeah this is
probably one of the worst ones i say
you've watched every marvel movie post
end game as well post end game what's
there been just no way home oh there's
been no way home there's been
black widows i've watched black widow
that was god awful
saying she was okay thank you
they've been taking big l's i feel these
movies have been
i just feel like they are still building
up no way home was really good no way
home was [ __ ] that was because i i i
kind of got what i wanted out of that
yeah i was like yeah i kind of expected
yeah
and yeah yeah
i'm sad because like i'm not that hyped
for any new marvel movies coming out and
doctor strange was one of the few i was
actually hyped about i was i've really
hyped about no way home and that meant
well that met my expectations um
oh yeah i i just felt that it was like
i you know when you you watch a movie
and i wanted to watch it to give my
thoughts yeah but at the same time i'm
like [ __ ] i don't want to give them
money so they think that i want more of
this right i don't want more of this
right like i'd rather i don't know like
i heard like morbius was really really
bad i've heard that's something i've
heard that's the worst marvel movie of
like or anything marvel related well
it's like it's not marvelous it's um
it's sony
okay that's not that's not empty so it's
not exactly mcu yeah yeah obviously
letters apparently already i don't know
i maybe watch it and give me your
thoughts because i'm really torn on it
because there were some moments that i
thought was really interesting and i
thought yeah okay this is good but the
rest of the time i'm like this just felt
like a movie they wanted to make just
because they were like well
i guess we could get benedict
cumberbatch to act himself out three
times and we could that could be fun and
it's just like all right
and uh yeah and
i don't know it was just really long
winded and boring and i i the moment my
popcorn ran out i was kind of i was kind
of like yeah i was kind of like i was
like that was the final draw well
there's no reason for me to be here now
i went with emily and us and they were
just laughing all the time as well at
some of the some of the dialogue was so
bad did they enjoy it uh they thought it
was really bad as well okay okay so
they're really enjoying like ironically
yeah there were some lines of dialogue
that was just like who wrote this like
this was like completely absurd like
this is like a four-year-old wrote here
yeah i don't know maybe viewers maybe
i'm wrong maybe you disagree with me let
me know what you think i haven't looked
at any critical reviews of it so i don't
know what the products are saying but i
would give it a picture it's the 10 hour
ten master yeah
for me it's a four out of ten yeah i was
very is it the worst marvel movie you've
seen no
what's the worst one you've seen
thought two was pretty bad oh that was
pretty good
that just sounds as bad from the name
yeah like thought two is pretty boring
like i'm looking forward to the new thor
uh yeah it just seems fun that that
seems fun yes four four four four four
yeah
did you have marvel movie fatigue i'm
just like i don't know just make blade
just make blade and make it good
at this point i definitely like i
definitely have marvel movie fatigue in
the sense where i'm just watching it
just to like keep up and there are like
i had marvel i had marvel movie fatigue
after like iron man 2. i just feel like
they're like fumbling right now they're
like what are these movies what are they
making
what the [ __ ] they're trying to say i
think they're fumbling i just think once
you end with endgame and it's just like
an end of like 10 years of build up it's
just like well [ __ ] how do you how do
you like how long is it going to take to
build up something that's going to be as
exciting because right now i'm not even
like invested in the characters as much
i was you know [ __ ] iron man or
captain america or like the main the the
main guys in like the previous
generation so it's like who is going to
be
that you know that main guy and i
thought it was going to be doctor
strange i you know i thought that was a
possibility
i don't know like a resident sleeper
dude that entire
i kind of shut off the first hour i was
like really bored yeah like watching
chiang chi was cool but i'm just like
i'm watching like a ushia movie and then
you have like you're barely relating
this to the mcu somehow whatever i'm not
really like i don't really care about
that you know
i made for the cool cool fights well i
was watching um uh your movie sucks and
uh he was doing his review of all the
like films of the year or the yeah yeah
yeah and like
70 of them he was like i didn't finish
it it was [ __ ] right a lot of people got
angry because they were like oh how can
you review a film if you didn't finish
it yeah
but i was like i i mean surely if you
can't finish a film that says that says
something
more than anything yeah yeah it's it's
like how critical do you want to be
it's more like yeah you can say you
really didn't [ __ ] like a movie and
not finish it because i've done that
plenty of times with anime you know but
if you want me to like properly critique
it then there's only so much i can
critique without seeing all of it
because i didn't see all of it you know
it's it's it's a
nuanced argument but i think you should
very much be allowed to say yeah i
thought something sucked
and uh because i didn't finish it yeah
yeah exactly i don't know yeah i feel
like
if i was watching that many movies as
well i wouldn't be yeah you got to start
like you know using your time wisely
right like you don't want to waste your
time on something that you think is just
going to be like your opinion is not
going to change on it
or not you're the best tv show that i've
watched came out recently
yeah dude i watched that too dude yeah
oh my god because i was gonna i was
gonna talk about some good [ __ ] that
i've watched
is probably one of the most interesting
and best tv shows i've watched in a long
time so sell it to me all right so uh
i'm gonna do a bad version then gone
could do the good version okay okay
the the the plot of this world is that
uh there is a procedure that you can get
that'll split your mind into two so you
have two consciousness one that goes to
work and one that does everything not
work right right so essentially there'll
be two characters in the same body
one that and they don't have any
memories of the other oh okay okay so
the person in work only existence is
work i don't know anything else right
and the person outside of work only has
outside of work and doesn't know
anything else and so it's kind of really
interesting because it's dealing with
all right well if you only worked all
the time you would probably get
miserable and want to not work all the
time so then they're trying to there's
kind of like really interesting side
plots of when they're trying to
figure out what their outside person is
doing and then the
outside person trying to figure out what
the inside person's doing and the
company they work at is really
mysterious we don't really know what
they do and so it's kind of like and
it's very very creepy
and cool it's really interesting you
should watch it so what's the good
version uh that was actually pretty good
oh he did it
i'll i'll do it i'll sell extra fluff it
up i'll do the i'll do the bad version i
guess yeah uh imagine black mirror was
good again
that's that's but but they had a good
premise and they ran with it yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah it's it because like i
watched the season and it felt very
black mirror-esque but like when black
mirror had very interesting ideas and
yeah it wasn't like [ __ ] just miley
cyrus going to like the bottom of the
barrel being like yeah we can make a
[ __ ] episode about this but like it
it has like a very interesting concept
as kind of said and they like run with
it and they explore
every single facet that you know i
wanted to explore out of it lately
definitely bring out like the ethical
aspect about it as well just like
is you know if you separate your
memories is that person essentially
a new person or is it just still you you
know because
you know in a certain
in a certain argument they are both the
same person because you come from the
same personality you know you just you
just don't share the memories of working
and the life outside of work but if you
separate the memories does that mean
that's like two separate people that are
living in one body as well chris chris
really liked it too i've chris funny
you've watched it it's on apple tv
though which chris watch it it must be a
masterpiece okay liked it too everyone i
know that sounds really cool though
literally everyone i know who watched it
really enjoyed
now
perfect because i couldn't do that
before oh cool i pretty much just saw an
article where they were like apple tv
has some really interesting shows and it
came up and i thought oh that looks
really good yeah and then the reviews
were insane yeah and i thought wow okay
and yeah honestly i really hope it
doesn't uh it doesn't like mess up the
landing because season one
was really really good season one's
really really good and holy [ __ ]
on a cliffhanger god [ __ ] damn it oh
the like that's also scary right because
people are saying the same thing about
black mirror as well
they were like damn season one though i
hope they stick the landing
yeah i think black mirror is basically
not gonna continue because it's in like
legal
uh battles for like ownership right yeah
it's in like legal trouble oh [ __ ] i
think um when they sold the rights
something was iffy and there's arguments
over who owns the rights to black mirror
so i think pretty much black mirror is
dead damn yeah i think well that doesn't
sadden me too much because they were
definitely like running out of ideas
they were definitely running out of
ideas so something scratched that itch
though and it was the show
that's good yeah yeah yeah
yeah because yeah with black mirror i
remember like season one and season two
being [ __ ] incredible yeah and then
season three was just like okay there
are some really good episodes and then
some are just like really weird episodes
and then season four onwards was just
like you are you know why are you
playing miley cyrus on this
i didn't even get to that point yeah
yeah i was even even worse i didn't even
watch season five sucked
yeah so i mean there's only like so many
ideas you can come up with with it being
like an anthology of different ideas but
severance [ __ ] great because it's
just one idea just explored to the
fullest uh very happy
such good acting yeah that actually is
so good like all these characters are so
creepy yeah like believable
yeah it was perfectly casted as well oh
yeah yeah yeah definitely check it out
yeah before it gets too high yeah yeah
yeah i think you won't watch
it
if if another person starts talking
about it i'll be like no no no
apparently no one is talking i literally
don't know anyone who's talking i've
never seen anyone talk about it so i
yeah if you want a really interesting
thing i'm going to watch it then before
this episode goes live in a couple of
days
if you watch one episode you'll be
hooked it's like where it starts so
strong yeah and it's really interesting
sure sure uh yeah watch it if you uh if
you can uh it's really interesting uh
actually like yeah amazing thank you
speaking about something that everyone
seems to be talking about now that i
have [ __ ] spy oh my god you [ __ ] i
didn't know how big it had gotten here
in the uk even like people who barely
watch anime they're like yo you're
watching spy family yeah
spike's family i'm like oh my god
everybody i pronounce the eggs because
because i'm a chat
yeah i mean it's been a while since i've
just seen an anime just blow up this
quickly i guess because i mean like
right from the get-go was like [ __ ]
sold i mean the manga was insanely
popular in japan yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i think it was good i was but like
i was i remember i was so scared because
i've been like a fan of the manga for
ages now and when i was like when i was
you know about to watch the first
episode i was like please please let it
be good please don't [ __ ] this up yeah
thank god they didn't right but like i
wasn't expecting yeah as you were saying
like i was not expecting it to be like
the talk of the town essentially yeah
because i expect because i just feel
like holy [ __ ] shone and jump are just
on a different level right now in terms
of in terms of like making mega hitters
because it feels like it feels like when
shown and jump release a new anime it's
like shonen jump and then every other
anime true pretty much because it like
it it doesn't even feel like you're
talking to a anime fan if they say they
watch shonen jump stuff because
everyone's watching shonen jump stuff
just imagine if we got a good berserk
adaptation
just imagine but like even even so i i
even don't think it would be as popular
as like spy spikes family or demon
slayer or something like that you know i
think the only the only other the only
ip that can really stand up to shonen
jump ips is like attack on titan that's
like that's like the outlier you know
because just a different shonen magazine
yeah yeah final season part one deluxe
edition yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i mean like it's just i haven't
read the manga of spike's family it's
just a really really good show yeah like
i haven't watched it i've been saving it
because i want to binge it all for like
one big serotonin boost yeah yeah it's
really solid like even from a manga read
it's really really solid it's just it's
just like it's
there's nothing i can really say about
it other than it's just a good show from
like a good manga with a [ __ ] amazing
adaptation
um like they nailed anya like
like as a character they're gonna be
seeing reaction images of her for the
next like four months i know right i
know every every twitter oh my god she's
so
[ __ ] adorable like she will
single-handedly save japan's like
[ __ ] asian population man depression
been mad quiet since
the japanese population aren't having
enough babies one anya you can have this
you could have
yeah like because like that was the only
thing i was worried about was like you
know because the dialogue is what made
spy family so [ __ ] good in the
morning so i was like
if they nail the voice acting and the
casting this is going to be huge and
they [ __ ] nailed the casting yeah at
least especially the japanese one like
the voice for anya is like perfect yeah
like what i think the big thing that
really makes it stand out is the cast
really nailed the chemistry between the
mom dad and the daughter yeah yeah yeah
obviously anya gets all the or the
spotlight but just the dynamic
um seeing the dynamic play out between
you know if if you don't know the
premise of spike's family it's a family
that has a spy in it an assassin in it
and anya who
is who can read minds that has a
telepathy right it's it's a it's a
really really weird mix of people but
they nail this family dynamic perfectly
because i remember just like it's equal
parts
funny
and wholesome as well yeah i remember
seeing like it's like an eos k that's
actually funny
everything from
a little bit
yeah a little bit a little bit of
everything because i remember like i
remember coming back from uh coming back
from the wedding uh like last weekend
and i remember all the newest episode of
spike's family just came out i watched
it and i just thought i was already like
high up in positive vibes and spike's
family like gave me such wholesome vibes
i almost [ __ ] cried because i'm like
just because of how like [ __ ] happy i
felt man i love how you're just like
[ __ ] the wedding the new spy family
episode just came out
that's where my happiness is right now
yeah that's
yeah i'm just like hold on sydney hold
on before you say your vows all right
i'm ready i'm ready
that's what i'm fighting for right now
are you watching the anime of spike's
family or are you just like no no no i
am actually watching it because like
yeah because like i watched the first
episode i was like oh [ __ ] this is like
actually a [ __ ] amazing adaptation so
yeah i am watching i'm not caught up to
the latest latest episode but um yeah
i'm like watching it kind of on and off
and uh yeah it's [ __ ] great i can see
why people are hyped about it yeah yeah
well like you know you were saying that
like oh yeah anu's like the new favorite
but like i don't know man i've seen a
lot of [ __ ] yore i have pictures and
it's like oh my god i i know she carried
talking about i don't even know what
their name is you said the name but
yeah i'm guessing it's the woman yeah
yeah yeah i'm like i'm like oh my god
first time in god knows how many years
where wife of the season is not a high
schooler
thank god well done it's it's a mother
it's a lava it's a milk it's actually a
milf thank you
well done guys i guess i'll have to
check it out
yeah i mean it was it's so weird just
because obviously i expected to be
popular i didn't expect it to be this
popular this quickly even demon slayer
took like 18 episodes yeah to really
burst into spy family just literally
took like two just to see if it uh
sticks around for the entire run
i think it will i would be very
surprised yeah it's only one season
because like the manga is doing like
insane numbers right now as well yeah i
saw like the the manga sales of like the
last the last month in japan and it's
like number one number two number three
number four number five all volumes of
spikes family yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it comes out all
right
gets a giant boost in sales yeah yeah if
you want to read the manga yeah so i'm
like man sharon jump just can't miss
right now because this i didn't even
think spike's family was going to it was
going to be the big show that they were
released this year i thought it was
going to be changing man yeah and then
what was that coming out that's coming
out this year as well i think it's the
summer i think like the summer of like
still next season like that's been like
everyone's like i'm so hyped for that
and i was like yeah when we hide like a
year ago
so fujimoto's released like three one
shots in that space oh my god dude which
you [ __ ] need to read okay yeah he he
brought out like i recently ran like a a
one shot uh called goodbye airy right by
him and it's like it's [ __ ] amazing
it's like probably one of the best one
shots i've ever read like the dude
manages to like
like basically
give the plot of like a movie's worth of
plot in like 200 pages oh wow and it's
[ __ ] incredible like yeah i read it
the other day because like twitch chat
was like
have you read it and so i was like and
you can read it for free as well oh on
the uh on the john plus uh i'm making it
sound like an ad i'm not paid for this
[ __ ] yeah
thanks julia i'll wait for my writing do
they need us to shout them out to know
that
exists
is on another [ __ ] level
yeah i've uh
shout out to disney by
loving the the way
doing with marvel or whatever waiting
for the royalties
walt i'm getting i'm waiting for you
coldwall
yeah i mean i'm sorry because like even
this like disney now have also come into
like the anime race you know [ __ ]
um they've picked up one of the best
seasonal animes i think our area is
airing the season which is like
summertime render which uh no one can
really watch right now because it's on
disney plus it's on disney playlist what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's on
[Laughter]
one more anime that was aired like a
couple of seasons back is in dc plus as
well
yeah
i see ads on like facebook like
everyone's like we shall continue on
disney plus
that's so weird
what a weird timeline we're living in
where disney is like you have your kids
ever heard of anime
that's so weird it's so surreal to think
that it's gotten to this point where now
disney's getting involved in the anime
arms race i thought they just like they
they had that thing with ghibli you know
i never thought they cared about like
anything else yeah like i always thought
like disney's like idea of anime was
just like princess mononoke yeah that's
a movie yeah is it anyway is it made by
hayao miyazaki oh no okay um i guess it
just it doesn't exist it doesn't exist
yeah
oh my god i saw you finally completed
elden ring as well dude albumin was very
fun how was that great game when you're
gonna play it
when i
when i have free time when i
have time to invest on being addicted to
something yeah yeah yeah almost amazing
yeah because i i saw you playing and i'm
like god [ __ ] down it looks so fun
but it's it's really fun but like
like i don't like i know as soon as i
start elden ring it's just gonna be like
when i started breath of the wild again
yeah well goodbye productivity yeah
goodbye productivity goodbye free time
because i am doing nothing but playing
this game how many hours did you sink
into it
nearly 70 i think okay that's not too
bad my first playthrough yeah yeah yeah
it's really really fun i i got to say
it's probably one of the best games i've
played
ever because i know people who like sank
like 200 hours instead oh yeah i still
haven't beaten it well because i mean i
like to play games on stream and i don't
i don't really want to right now i don't
want to keep playing it on stream yeah
yeah stream to a [ __ ] ton but like i
could easily you know do multiple
playthroughs and enjoy everything
i i didn't i didn't even see all of it i
missed so much stuff yeah because it's
you know it's open world so there's so
much to do
um but yeah honestly really really
amazing game so many cool fights really
fun really satisfying one of the best
game designs just hands down the world
oh my god dude like the world building
in that game it's just like second to
none you've never seen a world built
like what do you mean
i've never heard you talk about world
burning before i never
i i i i'm just like literally honored
you know you know something's like when
mr game mechanics over here is like
world building though
never cared but the fact that they built
so many cool set pieces yeah like just
these giant areas that you go to once
and you're like how much like hours did
they sink in building this yeah yeah and
you're there for like 10 minutes
yeah yeah there's one boss fight and
they built this whole giant thing
leading up to the boss fans like what
what the [ __ ]
like oh my god like just some of the
areas you're like this is so cool and
creative how the [ __ ] did you come up
with this yeah man
it's insane it's insane like the whole
like i've never cared about like how a
game
like world looks because it's like okay
you go into a place a boss arena you
leave no like every single aspect of
this world just so cool and it tells an
interesting story yeah it's honestly
such a good game
one thing that's really like surprised
me about uh what i've seen people
talking about about odin ring is like
how like
how friendly it is to beginners
yeah because i feel like because it's
open world and because there are so many
options you know in previous souls games
you know you get to like a hard boss or
something or you get like this one point
and people who
were not says you know were you know
were not as pro gamer or whatever you
know like a hard skill cap yeah there is
a high skill cap where they could do
nothing aside from you know try to beat
this boss and if they can be this boss
then you know i guess they just give up
or they just do something else but
because eldon ring is open world there
is just so much more opportunity like if
they
if they find a hard boss and they can
try doing something else they can grind
up a bit or you know i've heard that
there are many different builds and many
different like variations to um
to whatever what type of play style you
want to do as well and some are like
definitely easier than others oh some
are completely busted right um well it's
like the busted ones then it's the blood
one
there's like a bleed mechanic in the
game with certain swords that like cause
them to bleed and does percent damage
wow so percent damage on bosses you can
imagine is yeah big yeah and some swords
can apply very very quickly
so you can just chunk through bosses in
seconds with some builds right and other
builds not so much yeah like you know i
went i like messed around in the hard
area a bunch and then i went to the easy
area where i think i was supposed to go
yeah cause you can do whatever you want
really yeah yeah but i like absolutely
steamrolled this area like like two
shotting bosses and stuff yeah because i
was like i've gone messed around in the
really hot area that i shouldn't have
been in but you know i that's the way i
i enjoyed playing the game it was really
fun
and then it got really difficult towards
the end but that was really fun as well
because i was kind of over leveled a
little bit and so it was really fun i
just i had a really great time
there's not many boss fights that i
thought were bad all of the main bosses
were sick right so [ __ ] cool dude
yeah such cool bosses just a fun time
really fun time streaming it as well
would you say it's as difficult as
people make it out to be
again it's as difficult as you want it
to be yeah you know that you can summon
spirits and stuff so like things that
come in the fight for you and that helps
the locks it just takes aggro yeah like
the boss will stop hitting you and hit
something else so then that's like
that's more useful than them doing
damage yeah but some of them do damage
as well like a lot right um so yeah i
mean it's it's great what like play it
it's fun it's really really fun yeah i i
i wouldn't find the time to do it as i i
i'll be i want that to be i i hope
there's a game that can get game of the
year over this game because i'm i
that'll be incredible if i don't know
how that would happen yeah if there was
a game of things i hate being that guys
i could screw with the year but like i
don't know i don't know man have you
played the new kirby game though
i don't know i don't know what that's
pretty [ __ ] part in my mind i don't
know what could top this this year for
like a gaming experience that is
collectively agreed upon to be like an
amazing i mean i i'd be shocked i'd be
shocked i'd be very shocked as well i'd
welcome it i've seen these more games
for me i mean i haven't even played it
in a regular game it's pretty better
than it is metal gear revengeance yeah
i played played it was fun that was
great i mean i i'm just i'm just so
happy that revengeance memes have come
back i played it i haven't i haven't
played it
but i feel like i've experienced
like
ninety percent of it just through memes
itself but it's so good i played it i
did it on stream and uh yeah it was
amazing yeah what a fun game cut scenes
were as amazing armstrong is like one of
my favorite video game characters of all
time yeah like how how did how did the
japanese portray america better than
like most americans
most american
it's so good
it's just like it's so cool seeing a
game that just it just goes beyond time
like it's so impactful that it doesn't
matter how old it is i think one thing
that really impressed me with
like seeing people play metal gear
revengeance is just
like
the music is just [ __ ] insane
it's not just insane but like it kind of
matches up with like the
scene or like the level that you're
playing as well it's just like the
amount of
like that that's that's what sells
revengeance to me because i love anime
like fooly cooley that makes it feel
like you're watching
like a music video or something as
you're watching the anime but like
revengeance feels like you're playing a
music video
as like you're going along and that's
that's the biggest selling point for me
with with revenge it's just so good yeah
it's such a fun game and yeah the
mechanics are so tight and the cutscenes
are just hilarious because it's so
overly political yeah it's so funny
but also it's like some things he says
you're like wow
kind of a little on the nose
and then obviously all the memes that
came out of it are so good yeah if you
haven't played the game again i
recommend it how long did it take you to
complete i played it on hard and i kind
of regret it because i felt like there's
just so many
very hard moments because i wasn't very
good at the game it's because very fast
yeah um i think the medium is probably
the best way to enjoy the game initially
and it'd be like it'd be like five hours
but it's only like 10 hours because i
was like playing on hard and failing on
bosses all the [ __ ] times yeah so
hard
did you like play uh play in one sitting
on stream yeah one sitting yeah okay
okay and the last fight is so worth it
because the the armstrong is just such a
fun fight it's crazy dude the bottom
meshing dude yeah yeah yeah yeah
one way it's just like [ __ ] standing
there i feel like i'm part of the meme
experience now that's why i i played it
before but i'd gotten halfway and i quit
because i got stuck because it's really
it's a hard game yeah yeah yeah some of
the boss fights are [ __ ] hard yeah so
yeah i mean to play on uh normal if you
want to chill time yeah or easy even
like you want i definitely want to play
it yeah you can do it in five hours yeah
okay so like play one stream and and two
hours is cut scenes oh brilliant
it's my favorite yeah it's literally i
mean it is like a game yeah you know of
course so good it's so good if you
haven't played it go and watch it you've
probably watched all the the incorrect
telling of and all that where yeah it's
come from and i made it the [ __ ] up and
yeah making the mother of all omelets
here jack
i [ __ ] love that line that's my
favorite line
it's such a good game [ __ ] yeah cause
like i i feel like i would game
more like there's one console i've
really really [ __ ] won and it's the
steam deck you're on the
yeah yeah yeah yeah because like so many
times i'm just not fun to play on the
steam day actually yeah yeah because i
know it's it's it's less about just
the scene deck itself and it's more
there's so many games i just want to
play on the go yeah right because
because like
especially now we're traveling so much
and you know i don't stream as often as
you guys you know there's there's less
there's less time where i like sit down
in front of the pc or on account uh and
i game you know but if if there was like
that that's why like the console i game
the most on is probably like whenever i
play a switch game because it's just so
easy to just pick up whenever i need to
play it and just continue it uh at my
own convenience and like i was always
looking for a console to play
the more intensive games on uh while
also going on the go and like the steam
deck seems perfect for that but my god
is it like impossible to get right now
yeah the waiting list for that is
just like some people have got it how
the [ __ ] did
yeah i mean i i've seen like the prices
on ebay and then like twice to triple
the price um and the waiting this i
think right now is like a few months so
it's not too bad only a few months
that's that's i say that's not too bad
because i know like the people who got
like the first shipping of it they had
to like sign up a year plus before i
believe [ __ ] so i've heard mixed
things about it there's some good things
some bad things but overall i think uh i
think it's good yeah i've seen what's
the mixed things you've heard about it
uh i think i saw that the uh some games
it struggles with i can't remember what
i saw i remember there was some
downsides i can't remember though
weeks ago i watched these videos right i
remember it wasn't perfect yeah yeah
yeah i mean when is it when is it yeah
yeah as like i'm not like i'm not like
uh you know i don't really care about
the frame rates or like the fps or
whatever too much no i just want a
competent gaming experience on the go
for some games that i would normally
play on the pc or somewhere else and
that's seems that's all i really want
from the steam deck and that seems like
the perfect console to what i need right
now
yeah yeah definitely damn what are you
playing now joey how's
kirby i mean i haven't done the post
game stuff yet yeah but um yeah i don't
know i've just kind of been like [ __ ]
around just trying to play a bunch of
stuff i started playing uh kaizo emerald
which is like one of the honest
pokemon mods oh okay that mod is hard as
[ __ ] it is so it took me
six hours to beat the first gym jesus
christ yeah it's hard as [ __ ] why is it
hard because
not only is like well first of all every
trainer is unavoidable so you have to
fight every trainer and every trainer
is optimized so literally every trainer
fight is like fighting a professional
pokemon player wow so like the moves are
optimized and like all the ivs are
optimized and everything
and you're basically just going against
that jesus christ and it's it's it's
intense as [ __ ] have you seen those
people beating uh the pokemon games with
level one pokemon oh yeah yeah yeah
it'll be yeah they're like small
right yeah yeah well they're like as you
swap out poison substitute they see all
their oh
yeah ever like you're like i'll try and
play pokemon competitively you play and
then someone's like substitute they make
poison spikes yes reflect and he's like
stop let me hit it let me hit your
pokemon
literally i knew it was bad because
for one like the first rival fight yeah
it just spammed sand attack like seven
times
and then it just slowly drained my
pokemon to the point where i lost the
first battle oh my god this isn't gonna
go well at all
oh [ __ ] i wanna do more pokemon runs
yeah that's so fun that's like so i'm
probably gonna continue that because
that's just like you know as like a long
time pokemon game i'm like this is the
first time where i'm like finally a
pokemon game is actually a challenge
finally a worthy finally a worthy
opponent like you thought you thought
nuzlocks were hard like this game is
like [ __ ] hard yeah so what's the
base game that mods uh pokemon emerald
it's all the mods from like emerald
right it's usually like third gen yeah
usually emerald or i don't know maybe
it's because it's like
a fan favorite or like uh you know it's
i mean it's a solid game yeah yeah yeah
but there's also a lot of mods for you
know like you know gen 4 and stuff like
that there's tons of mods like breath of
the wild and stuff i don't know yeah i
mean it sounds cool though i really want
to play like multiple like breath of the
wild
but i'm also scared to [ __ ] my switches
yeah yeah exactly right
well breath of the wild is one of the
games where you can definitely see that
being like a mods have modest heaven you
know oh yeah because you have so much
freedom in that game as it is in the
base game you know i can't imagine how
it would be i've seen like so many cool
like mod videos
everything's among us
like everyone's at the among us
[Laughter]
i like it i just like it it's like the
one the [ __ ] uh the point crow video
where like you say shrek it's summoned
10 shreks into the game oh yeah
which is the dumbest video but it was so
fun to watch yeah yeah like when is the
mangas gonna die when am i gonna stop
when am i gonna stop finding among us
memes funny because i thought i would
like
i feel like they've gotten funnier i
don't i don't i don't know why
because they're starting to become
ironic that's what yeah the among us vr
yeah yeah yeah yeah i was gonna say yes
it looks good it looks fine that
generally looks good that might be like
a game i can finally finally get vr just
going for the clips of like xbox mics
and someone's like this with their among
them
dude
it was this guy
i can't wait i can't i can't wait to the
credit card on on vr you're like
i'm so hyped freddie i actually looked
awesome yeah yeah it looks fun yeah i
can't wait for the absolutely i'm hoping
that they do like
include the voice chat within the
like having to like log into discord in
vr and like having to like log out
through proximity chat yeah yeah yeah i
also it would be also perfect if like
you did it on the omnidirectional uh
like moving pad as well like oh yeah we
have to like run through the halls and
[ __ ] that was so fun
impractical yeah yeah yeah yeah once i
coming out because i saw the trailer no
idea they didn't have a release day
which normally means whenever the [ __ ]
they finish it
it's probably a while which could be
next year
they should i hope they charge for it
because i wanted to i have worth their
time yeah yeah i mean it feels like this
has this because they completely just
remade the game right so they've
basically just built a new game
essentially from the ground up basically
i don't think they could have used
anything from their previous uh previous
game which was originally a mobile game
to going full on vr
so yeah i'm very crazy to try it out
might finally be able to like dust off
the via uh no not the vive the valve
valve index which i've never i still use
mine it's pretty good vr chat's pretty
fun yeah yeah
it's just such a such a hassle to set up
yeah i kind of wish i got the oculus or
whatever which because that just seems
so much more convenient than like you
know
i get you get more freedom with the
index and everything and it's like
higher resolution but i still haven't
streamed on the my oscilloscopes because
i'm like dreading to set it up yeah
optimize the index it's because i have
the things permanently up there yeah
it's super easy i literally just plug in
the headset open up steam and i'm i'm
literally doing it so it's it's super
painless for me even then i still get
tired doing it i get exhausted yeah
after like three four hours of like
running around in vr i'm like i'm like
spent i'm like i'm surprised you can
even spend that long like i can't i
can't go more than like two hours yeah
in any game yeah yeah well it's really
good like chat is so
and the games in vr chat are so good
you eat your heart out like a book
[Laughter]
shaking your powers with the people
don't you understand
uh yeah but i mean uh i guess this is uh
this is gonna be i guess we have a bunch
of guests coming on there yeah yeah
that's right so this is gonna be the
last boys episode for uh for for a while
because i'm sorry people happy about
because we've had like the longest
period of no guess yeah and i feel like
you can tell because people are like
what are they when's the next guest too
it's it's our bad i mean it's been hard
because you know guests have been
limited because you know japan has uh
can't be like let's invite chris on a
[ __ ] tenth time yeah exactly we could
have we wanted to we could have invited
back more guests we thought
i just want to try and
keep trying fresh yeah keep keeping
fresh obviously christopher though yeah
basically chris christie will come back
on any time basically whenever he's in
tokyo comes on yeah so hopefully if you
guys want more guest episode you'll be
getting a lot coming yeah yeah now that
the world is opening up it's kind of
like the floodgates uh now
i'm sure i'm sure i i can't wait for the
one of the boys gonna just go back to
the three of them because we're probably
gonna have a lot of guest episodes in a
row yeah so i'm i know people are gonna
say that because people but people do
like the
people don't like the non-guest episodes
people do actually really like them i
know a lot of people say that they're
their favorites yeah of course yeah uh
but yeah we have a lot of guests and
then we'll try and sprinkle in ours
between yeah it'd be interesting to see
how people like it yeah it's going to be
a new kind of trash taste i think it's
uh
season three
i guess it kind of is season three it's
season three um yeah it's gonna feel a
bit different uh we're not gonna spoil
what it is but yeah it's trash tastes
gonna feel a little different for a time
so look forward to that yeah i hope you
enjoy it hey look at these patrons
though yeah right oh yeah it's been so
long since i've recorded an episode i
forgot that we have to shout out the
people this is like what was the thing
we have to say
my god yeah but hey if you want to
support the show then go over to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us memes on the subreddit
and if you had a face listen to us on
spotify and uh yeah
see you at ax i guess now that we've
finally said that in the episode
see you then all right see ya
[Music]
you